okay all right let's start great thanks
any of that hit podcast of the [ __ ]
year that's a year hurts it's down right
here parties come free I've grown a free
yeah I mean I don't didn't get me wrong
every morning I wake up go and do I got
it do I got it yeah I'm offered you
twenty three-year-old with I saved this
flower I know I told this company I go
mikoto uh-oh hey Bert Kreischer is
coming they go witness any tent we're
gonna send you 10 bottles
thousand-dollar bottle you know we're
saying ten bottles I'm at perfect my
heart will tear that thing up dude I sit
down I pour myself a little sippy sip
it's my birthday week not a big deal my
birthday week seven holy [ __ ] drink your
problem alcohol boom anyways so I pour
myself a drink but it goes no I'm not
drinking
yeah the [ __ ] wrong with you do take
October no dude I'm off the road for
like eight weeks now it looks like so
I'm [ __ ] gonna [ __ ] lean up and
get healthy as [ __ ] I literally do
here's the deal if I decided to go hard
in this this self-imposed state break it
would be [ __ ] dead cuz I there's
nothing to do I would start drinking it
for I would drink until 2:00 in the
morning if I got to put some parameter
on me because this is like what is it
idle hands are the devil's playground
yeah you you can drink are you one of
those guys if I drink one glass of
whiskey it let's say 2:00 in the
afternoon
I'm done for the rest of the day no work
out I'm not working it out I'm problem
let me definitely not drive in you can
keep drinking though oh yeah oh yeah
okay and and like for me I found I've
kind of found my my parameters if I
drink when I'm on the road doing tours
if I drink after my shows I can drink
one out until whenever bus leaves go to
the next day if I don't drink during the
day at all I am a hundred percent
[ __ ] perfect right but man those
morning drinking's oh that's a problem
the long day it's and morning drinking
when we pulled it in New Orleans the day
you know the day everything broke down
last week we flew to New Orleans got the
red-eye
eight hit Bourbon Street started having
cocktails took a meeting about a movie
slide slide into a meeting have more
cocktails everyone's out we go back to
the bus crack another beer am i coming
to go to bed I get a call from my agent
he's like hey we're not sure about the
no no my my my my my promoter comes in
says hey we should get on the phone and
talk that Live Nation oh no no Jobu it's
a different type of thing I and so they
said we sit on the phone and talk so we
all of a sudden I'm like about what and
they're like you know and I had the week
before I was at Constitution Hall
constitutional is pretty big it's almost
like 4,000 seats I did two shows on the
first show I didn't think anything of it
I really was like I was like dude this
coronaviruses [ __ ]
Seki show I heard some people coughing
and way too early to be coronavirus but
I heard people coughing I thought if
this if that had been coronavirus and
there were no registered cases in DC at
the time but if it had been I would have
just spread it I was just I would have
been walked off I i sat down with my
guys we poured a drink and I was like
this shit's gonna get serious very
quickly and then and then I sat down
they did the numbers or what how many
people I was doing this weekend and
they're like if you get in front of this
then you know you're not responsible at
all for this mother of people get
affected if you get in front of this and
then just cancel now you're gonna look
like an [ __ ] but my thing about this
is like I would like to know who exactly
is telling who are these biologists that
are telling the [ __ ] politicians and
I'd also like to know rate the what
they're saying yeah all I keep hearing
is that something some authority figure
goes we're closing everything down I'd
like a little [ __ ] explanation
because I'm still well these are
scalable you talk to Eddie Bravo here me
too but these are steps so they can't
just quarantine everybody shut down for
two weeks because then the nation would
be in complete kick right so it just
it's steps I understand all gonna get
quarantines shut down for two weeks yeah
this is that where we won't be able to
but they just stay just so what did they
say yesterday's yesterday CDC says 50
plus 50
today it's 1010 on the Friday of Trump's
just had to talk on the ride and he said
keep it to groups of fit of 10 don't go
to bars that's a suggestion it's a
suggestion they can't
that suggestion is gonna come down
because what's 1/2 step did you see the
picture of everyone in Nashville going
hard as [ __ ] and the girl wrote
Nashville undefeated like going it just
takes one person yeah and it's
everywhere well but you also like the
symptoms take they say you know days or
weeks to show up but also the those
people in Nashville those are young
people ok yeah if you're young and
you're yeah my young I mean under 16 or
8 or 5 that's what they I heard look I
don't mean interrupt no no no no we are
at that group chat you Andrew Schultz me
and Chris D'Elia and I was I was at the
airport waiting on this how fast this
ship moves waiting to do my show in New
Orleans because we're Texas everyone and
I talked to Live Nation that's more than
just I go dude I'm head of the airport
my brother's flying out there my opener
my future are we good he goes we're good
that's at 9:00 a.m. I Drive to the
airport I'm at the airport Bert's in New
Orleans I'm like hey you're doing your
show you us as of now we'll see
and then you never like dude don't say
anything yet let me do it but I'm gonna
cancel so I go I call Justin Raj I go
dude Burke just cancelled I know we're
not doing however 70 million people that
he's doing but still it's 1,500 1,500 a
legit sathya true but people to bring
into a group in one place I think I
don't wanna be responsible this so you
sure we're getting us right dude a talk
line is right now you're good and then
take a sail this was crazy ticket sales
went up they go you're over the number
in Atlanta you sold out the New Orleans
it's there they come late so it's it's
over a thousand now and so I'm like what
I'm on the plane I go are you sure we're
good and I just pick my stomach like
this doesn't seem right man dude that's
the one the one thing that freaks me out
Wayne we're literally everyone sitting
down born I went ding oh yeah I got a
panic sweating I mean I gotta get off
she goes
excuse me oh listen I'm a stand-up comic
I've shows in Atlanta New Orleans
they're getting canceled and I was just
fine with that you need to let me off
she was let me talk to the pilot you
know the doors are closed no they let
pop off okay so I'm gonna kid my seat
let pop off that's the that's the weird
part is and not by the way this is real
inside baseball but the promoter said
just so you know we had showed we had
two shows in Huntsville
and he was like and we meet we had still
had tickets available in the Late Show
he's like they're still selling like
hotcakes
like there's like weren't like it was at
86% for the second show he's like we're
at 96% we're gonna sell that out
like no one's worried about this so if
you wanted to show do the show I just
saw another responsibility right well I
thought my dude it's to your point I
don't mean they're up you know did it my
thing was is like dude my bros are gonna
come out my 18 to 36 demo they're gonna
come out cuz they know they're healthy
and this ain't [ __ ] my bros are gonna
come out my fans are gonna [ __ ] come
out if somebody gets it there and it you
know goes like that and then they go
home it goes like that
then I'm responsible like I just can't
they think good dude look at that take a
sec next time you go into one of these
theaters look at the ushers and look how
old they are
oh they're a hundred all of them on
there a hundred I went into the theater
that night and kind of looked around I
was really [ __ ] deflated and but then
I looked at all the Oscars hanging out
and I was like oh there's not one of
them under 60 okay but here's your
chance so that's when I take my dude
Burt just and by the way I've been wrong
very enemy why then if we know that the
statistics are how many people send me a
man that it's IFT well they don't know
where they're all 80 the other minimum
age of death okay so they're 80 so so so
plus we don't know how many people have
I understand more but I just feel like
and a lot of this is we're learning
about this yeah but I I don't understand
why then the man that is if you're an
old person stay inside is it because
it's impossible to contain it and more
poppy I guess it's impossible not to
catch it when you're an old person
because if you're old person and just
the normal flu is around I need your
[ __ ] right yesterday
I go to the mall right packed nobody
gives a [ __ ] I go them all outside
people do not go outside nor chose
outside Nordstrom's a little table where
there's that coffee there's a table at
price it's 14 people the Knitting old
ladies and dudes knitting they're
probably all 80 to 90 yeah didn't give a
[ __ ] I hope I hope I am [ __ ] so long I
hope people in New Orleans go I'm never
gonna come see you again cuz you did
that and you overreacted I hope that's
it nobody hope I'm overreacting
I hope that
that's a doctor a friend of mine said he
said the best-case scenario is that we
overreacted but he's he's in UCLA and he
said call me up mr. knee well he's my
neighbor and he said listen I'm not
gonna let my kids play with your kids
only because I'm I'm working with this
all day now we're starting to see cases
and I think it's responsible for me too
because the kids can carry it and I said
that's fine
and they'll hope for the best expect the
worst but he sent me an article he said
no he said this that what we want to do
this because it will be best case
scenarios that we overreacted that's a
good thing that's that's me is overreact
like like my kids are yeah yeah I'm not
going out not going out for st. Patty's
Day so my demos point four percent
twenty twenty to thirty nine this and by
the way point four but yeah but that's
also like worldwide and here's the other
thing there's so many because with the
because there's outliers in China
because like 80% of the people smoking
but also China lies right who knows what
the [ __ ] you how many people died there
they coverage it but the other China
anyways but the other terrible food
anyways but the other thing is is they
can't tell only rich people can test for
it it's only the rich again tested
there's so many more cases than we know
if yeah but how many we know how many
people died 50 yeah maybe a little more
let's say let's say 200 but there's so
many people with it I thought I had it
three weeks ago we went to the Rangers
game in Texas or New York in New York we
went to the Knicks game in the Rangers
game right so we're at the Rangers game
and they come up and they're like hey
man we won't throw you on the jumbotron
Wow we'd love for you to kill a beer
well they did it at the Knicks game and
they're like can we have you kill a beer
and I was like yeah of course rip my
shirt off kill a beer up on the
jumbotron yeah Madison Square Garden
goes nuts right yeah I don't even know
who I am
I'm just some dude ripped this shirt off
killed his beer st. Patty's Day on
Netflix like I'm all in it go to the
name range again the next day they're
like come on like yo shirts coming off
kill a beer and I had been like I've
been instructed not to take my shirt off
who told you that I will tell you guys
so did we no no
it's so I tell them I go I'm not taking
my shirt off and we're at a hockey match
it's cold I go bond kill a beer and then
I great we're coming in three I go I'll
have a beer and then I get one and so I
take this everyone pour some beer in
here's I think sharing beers and then
they go we're coming either they pass me
that beer I'm like I just got Corona he
did a schooi yeah you did in New York
Zoe and so so I was dude I in my brain I
start [ __ ] I wake up the next day I
go oh I'm getting it I'm definitely
getting it but it's been now two weeks
I've never I've never had a symptom and
I don't have a coffee and I ran five
miles this morning
hell yeah but the thing is is that this
is why I pulled back drinking you know
sometimes you're able to Center Brogan
and you feel like he's talking to you
like he'll be criticizing someone or
something up and your lights you be like
wait is he talking about me I know he's
talking about Crona hot guy and he's
like so who needs to be concerned and
he's like the guy goes you know people
with an unhealthy diet people that are
obese you know Pete and Joe goes people
who drink a lot and I'm going talk about
me he goes now people unhealthy diet
don't really work out they drink too
much they don't sleep enough and I'm
like these are all things I've been
taxing with Joe not sleeping a lot I
could tell you work out all one time he
said based on that Rogan said this he
was talking around white and I never
talked about this but it was just such a
weird thing he goes like this he goes
yeah I mean acting is so different than
stand-up and it forces you to compromise
yourself Bryan Callen Mike my good
friend Bryan Callen yeah he goes
auditioning ruined him it just because
it ruined him because he had to like
squeeze everybody when he's in the
audition to demand these people to it'd
just ruin him alone
Radim grade right like what the [ __ ] you
know what do you mean ruin me I didn't
know you look at me that way was so
weirdest [ __ ] and rhomboids kept
talking about something else you're not
oh backup anytime I hear drinks too much
doesn't work hard enough has no
discipline yeah yeah crazy too I but no
but not though like I don't know Brogan
discipline I have like good discipline
for a guy who's like a high functioning
outlaw well that's like Rogan one time
when I talked to Nick DiPaolo Kate
Brogan we were young man and he goes he
goes look at him look at this forums
it's like a little he's like a ball of
hate oh yeah he goes he's a veiny ball
of hate I go yeah hey jump when you
don't work out and before you could get
that sentence out running list I've
never not worked out I never questioned
his mood it was just a different enemy
he said he's always been the most
intense person he smokes weed okay you
guys met him you've known him since he's
been a hothead I knew him when he was 28
27 26
you have no idea did you go did you ever
open for him Burt no no I wish I wish I
wanted to I had an issue I would open
for someone and I had an issue about
power who Jay Mohr I mean I just feel
bad I don't I feel bad I don't want to
talent something I'm talking bad about
the guy you know obviously our
relationship kind of fell apart and we
don't speak but the issue was it was
sometimes it was it was uneven and there
was it was more employee than friend but
we were friends it would it would [ __ ]
it would just be [ __ ] up at times and
it's ultimately what made us stop
becoming friends a big problem it was
and it was unhealthy I remember so many
times that I so many times I would say
something thinking I was talking to my
friend and then it would turn out I was
talking to my boss and he would let me
know hey you're talking to your boss
right now that's nothing and I was like
oh and so and i i'm i yeah that's a
problem and it's but it's also like like
derek derek and a sondik post on my
feature he goes you know why always like
[ __ ] with you on tour but no matter what
you do or what he goes because you treat
me as a period he goes I've opened for a
ton of big names and he goes they don't
treat me like that
they make me carry their bags they never
made me carry you
oh yeah I've heard of that talk Amelia
about that's all who does that
because I will I mean you carry my bags
what what so here's the thing with me I
I train and I train hard and I trained
to fight and when I fight I like to
turtle up I do the UL Romero thing where
I'll turtle cuz I don't want to gas
right also you're boring
no well yeah but I'll turtle up and then
explode on you right because I use my
explosive power here's the thing dude
hey I use I use my explosiveness now
here's the thing what what I do now is I
can go full-bore all day oh wow all
night okay so I'm Jay my mother
I got my Kenyan runner I explode on you
in round one I was boarding two rounds
I've the bedroom could be in the cage be
on the street I explode everywhere now
listen the reason I can do that is why
why why Bret it why don't don't touch my
don't smack my hand or the surf-and-turf
did I took some sir if I be delayed
order the Serpentor beats dude I trained
with jiu-jitsu I Trent going for a Trent
karate
I took my B delete that means I've got
crazy stamina over a hardened 40 pro
teams to use beat elite extends
endurance improves energy and stamina
what is it it promotes oxygen efficiency
throughout the body so right now do you
get this from eating beets no you can't
you can't eat enough B now it's
basically beat beets have a certain
chemical compound and oxygenate the
plotter you know I used to just just do
beat water
I stood drain beets I still [ __ ]
juice beets so I grew oxygen levels but
you can't do it man do what Brian does
take came to the next level with beet
elite by going to live human calm slash
fighter live human that's Li b e:h um a
n.com slash fighter live human calm
slash fighter
oh yeah that's Li ve human dot-com /
fighter to get 10% off your first
purchase the team at human is making
this offer exclusive t fat k listeners
you won't find this deal anywhere else
me on DS are all over dude they're
taking the world over they sent me some
elephant undies a match and salted
my kid went what are those I want shut
your little mouth they're Papa's I love
a man the best underwear on planet Earth
dude it's all these dude get rid of the
old ones it's time to end that talks
relationship with your old [ __ ] stain
under if you have these authors endless
options for those looking to up there
under game you can choose a monthly
membership which I did build a pact and
can even match your undies with your
other half talk about your socks man
mmm these are made with soft sustainable
fabric available in sizes extra small to
4x l the thick boys you can get on it
right now too from black unicorn me on
these prints are made for yourself
expression you have coffee and you have
to have your mug you'll do that with
your me undies you'll choose those
around okay it's off and free shipping
this is a no-brainer especially because
they have a hundred percent satisfaction
guaranteed you don't like him cool money
back is 50% of your first order
free shipping 100% satisfaction
guaranteed go do me undies comm slash
fighter lets me undies calm slash
fighter it was there was so many times
where and it wasn't all the time it was
just like and it was never creatively I
think creatively we saw each other as
peers
it was just being like weird [ __ ]
times so one time Rogan said he's like
why don't you come to the when you come
to mmm the UFC come over for me and come
to you have seen yo rogues playing
theaters how long does it's got to be
like eight years ago nine years ago and
that was a while ago when I was like and
Tom's like you should do it man
I think Tom's like I'm going cuz Tom you
still Penn Tom needs to open for him too
so Joey and I just decided not to
because I didn't want I like Joe and I
have so much respect for Joe and in a
way you know I don't know how you guys
feel but I really look up to him in a
lot of ways I look up to him I have I'd
lean on him for advice about things
before I make any decision gotta text
Joe Rogan Bryan Callen and top Feldman
yeah yeah those are the three horsemen
for me and so I did never wanted to I
never wanted to look like an employee to
him I will always want to be like a peer
and appear that at least I knew where I
looked at him that he would always look
at me in the same level and it's always
I'm sure he's always looked at me as
like a little brother that he could help
fix but but so yeah I never I never
opened for him and and and I
it is I would kind of miss it I heard
these great stories and one of the
things he always said he's like you got
a tour with people you like and I didn't
do that I was wanted to work with the
people in the local towns and meet
people and in stand help build the scene
and help common local comics get good
spots and I did it up until I was
selling out clubs Adhan shows on
Thursdays $35 tickets
I was always letting local guys open for
me and then when I got the tour bus I
was like all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
bring just comics that I like you're a
guy yeah and I said I feel really guilty
I remember saying this to them what time
I go I feel really guilty that I'm not
helping the local comedy scene and
letting guys do spots and shame Torres
goes he's like Dawg you met me in
Portland I opened for you in Portland
Dave Williamson goes I met you in Miami
and hey-zeus Trejo goes I met you an
Irvine yep and I was like oh that's
right that's right that's where I got
you guys I let you guys know I [ __ ]
owe you doing it yeah but the other
thing is is uh I was doing the same
thing because uh because when you're
always doing sets at the Comedy Store
like you [ __ ] legends are there like
it's it's the pro ball of [ __ ] comedy
so I don't I didn't know where I fit in
because I'm always looking up on my
older brother I consider you guys older
brother so I was always looking up to
everybody and so when I'd go on the road
I could kind of figure out where I was
in the lines if that makes sense you
have a guy to do how long you do it
eight years okay cool man
well you're not brick Christ you're not
Bryan Callen you're not Giovanna Chris
D'Elia or Joey Diaz or Joe Rogan Tom
Segura so I can I could navigate where
I'm at so I did that for a year and then
I was gone I just want but then
sometimes the shows would be great if
depend what market you're in Miami
there's monsters down there if you're in
DC there's monsters New York off sea
monsters Oh bro our single monsters but
sometimes you go certain markets and as
brian says it's a disaster I'm talking
last night but it was training camp for
me because I'd have to dig out of the
biggest hole because the person in front
of me had puppets they had some gimmick
where it wasn't staying I'm like what
the [ __ ] were you thinking bro I saw I
saw we're up to that point you remember
when we're doing is when I very first
starting you and I were doing a casino
and they go this guy's gonna go first he
doesn't magic in any yesterday's jokes
you go not happening and I was like I
don't give a [ __ ] - not happening I got
I go I go Brian I don't I don't care
dude I'm fine you go no it's not
happening Brendan you're young comic
this guy's been he was telling you been
working the guy goes 30 years us nice
thing happen the guys like there with
this I'm not having to come up there
with [ __ ] fire rabbit brandi is a
rabbit rabbit like a birdies like you're
really [ __ ] and Brian does not happen I
go to kids if I can find girls let me
talk to guys dude you're just starting
this guy's Englishmen do it three years
tricks
trust me his tricks easy grab that he's
gonna blow the roof off this [ __ ]
local place and then you have to fall in
ain't happens and I was like what now my
girl thank God for Brian okay in West
Palm this is how long 15 years ago 15
years ago I'm opening for Louie CK it's
Sunday night and it's a dead [ __ ]
room I'm out at the bar and they got a
book of of hypnosis tricks right where
you go okay I want you to think of an
animal think of a color think of a no
and I'm doing it to the bar staff and
it's working so well I'm just [ __ ]
around on stage and so I bring the book
on stage with me and I do some comedy
and then I do one of these okay I won't
ever want to think of a number Oh think
of a color think of a state think of a
car now think of an animal are you guys
thinking about an elephant and
everyone's like crazy my name is Bert
Kreischer Louie Louie gets over stage
goes hand me the [ __ ] book I guess
we're doing tricks tonight oh he's like
I guess we're not doing comedy Oh
it was like I think I'm gonna [ __ ] this
here tonight did he come backstage like
you what the [ __ ] you said why would you
bring a [ __ ] book onstage [ __ ]
five minutes a [ __ ] mind trick one
thing I don't do is recommend anybody
who I haven't seen and I have done that
before and it resulted in disaster hi
guy strange cat nice guy but not a comic
and and was kept saying I wanted to
stand up let me let me I'm getting into
it can you help me out I want to open up
over the knife you know me I'm nice guy
I'm nice guy so I'm like I say to my one
buddy I go is he funny cuz it's funny
man I mean you know he's funny I go yeah
but comedy is a different thing just
makes me laugh you know beer I go home
have you seen it performing this no but
I hear good things I go try god I did
yeah alright now put him on I put him on
and it's a it's a local show but it's
like they're comics and then you know
well I I didn't get there in time I I
get there yeah and while he was perform
I friends don't look at me like this
they're like hey dude Hawaii guys what
happened what who was that guy well he
showed up as an alien from another
planet
oh I am I am an alien he was doing
comedy like that dead silence and
wouldn't get off the stage for way too
long
and they were lighting him but there's
no lighting because he's not he's not a
comedy show so alien how you dressed up
like an alien but you didn't tell me he
goes yeah dude I didn't really get it oh
okay all right dude that's so [ __ ]
bad they were like you can't put an
alien you can't put an alien I brought I
brought the first time I ever brought
someone this is one of my favorite
stories to tell first time I brought
someone I bring Tom Segura up to
Sacramento now this is when Tom had hair
and he used to comb it back and butt
you've been doing comedy long in the top
he gets up is this by the way
fat Tom no beard Tom like button down
like relaxed shirt Tom a year's demon
commies Tom at this point he's this is
this is that Tom okay this is that Tom
he is to comb his hair back you comb it
all the way back right he's gotten a lot
better much so he goes up yet dude
thirty minutes maybe yeah yeah Tom's
maybe you're doing stand-up I had maybe
like four years
I'm guessing five years and he goes up
and it's Sacramento it's a be club it's
called laughs unlimited is a tough crowd
you had really improv and do a little
crowd work to get them with you and Tom
goes up with straight material and it's
straight like aggressive material and
they are not having it and he is not
getting laugh not cuz not funny it's
[ __ ] not you know he's doing four
years a laugh not one laugh joke stops
they don't realize that stop starts a
new joke they're not confused huh what's
going on and he starts sweating are you
in the back on the back watching he's
sweating and as he as he continues to
sweat his hair starts flattening to his
head right and it's spinning and at one
point there is one line of hair there's
one comb line of hair like this and
everyone is watching their nose no
hearing a joke they're hearing that one
line of hair and his dog bombs and the
hair collapses and the room goes he gets
off soaking wet knee goes that didn't go
good no it's like no like this really
aggressive rape joke I think don't open
with a rape joke and he was like you
think dude he I've seen him bomb so
[ __ ] we waited we did we did we did
one time we we did a Hawaii together
right and they go be clean whatever you
can like this is this is [ __ ] this is
dirt 13 years ago lana just had ila so
13 14 maybe 12 years ago
so we do why the person we're supposed
to go with cancer the last minute Tom's
good friends with Russell Peters he goes
let's see if we get Russell he's a big
international act they booked Russell to
me Tom Russell Peters we're having a
great time we're doing fun things we go
to we go to one of the shooting cut
things and the guy and Russell wheel
Russell you want to go needles I mean
I'm gonna go shopping today well okay so
Tom and I take the girls and we go there
in the first thing the guy says is we've
got one rule here on Pearl Harbor if
it's brown and it moves you shoot it and
we're a good thing we didn't invite
Russell I know I bomb I bomb immediately
and I'm a little dirty
you opened I open because it was a rough
show so I go I'll open it Tom I'll give
you an easier spot to me and then
Russell kill different Tom's like yeah
they go whatever you do don't make fun
of Hawaii and don't bring up Pearl
Harbor that war and we're like okay sure
not that's not in either of our acts I
go up and I eat it and Tom decides to
pivot and goes up and he goes hey man
it's beautiful here in Hawaii they say
island life is slow I didn't know they
were talking about their metabolisms man
Hawaiians are fat you know I was walking
around the base today and I got lost
luckily I ran into a bunch of Japanese
guys they really know their way around
this base huh and now we can hear the
[ __ ] commander going what the [ __ ] is
going on what the [ __ ] is going on Tom
gets off the host the host of the night
the host of the night and goes put your
hands together for Russell Peters we
realize we're sitting with 12,000 people
have been taught if it's brown and it
moves oh I hope he doesn't move around a
lot I miss you know those hurt they hurt
so bad he ate the breakfast the next
morning we went to the beach and we were
like I was like how you feeling he's
like not good never do this again
put the [ __ ] two giggle about it now
is like greatest iconic Ealing I want a
closer reason me Tom and Christina and
Leigh and my wife are so close is that
we sat at the beach the next day getting
drunk and I'm just commiserating about
how bad it we would Tom met where we
we met he was I was opening for Jay Mohr
and we were Brea and he was in the how
long jumper is this my this is it's got
it before I had kids so sixteen years
seven sixteen years married 17 years I
walk in toms watching the FSU game Jay
wasn't having a good day Thomas just was
never good down right so Tom's watching
the FSU game I went to have as you I
walk in and I go hey man
FSU and he goes yeah he found I said I
want to have studios that's my favorite
team I go hey I'm Burton he goes I'm Tom
J walks in and he was the [ __ ] you guys
watching and Tom goes they have a shoe
game I got hundred dollars on it and it
looks good videos you're the host you
make fifty dollars a night and you
hundred all your [ __ ] idiot walks out
at a good time ago hey what were the
tour I love it I don't get why you and
Tom don't tour together it's good like
why not do it two bears one cave where
the [ __ ] it is why don't we want to do a
tour like that like that would sell like
a you guys walk through the biggest kind
of the world that would sell like
[ __ ] hotcakes
I think ultimately honestly I mean not
to like show how the sausage is made
no no not money at all really he's
wrapped by and I'm reprobate and neither
our agents want to do business with each
other [ __ ] yeah I know but it becomes
super complicated because I'm even just
like even like like that [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
it's why Justin when justice started its
very wisely just started look yeah he
started gathering although all the like
the death squad comics and it was such a
brilliant move and I don't think
everyone looked at it that way
that's why I always respond to expect
justice Marty was just yeah and he had
all these guys he was like he could
easily do a [ __ ] tour put together you
well you guys did the [ __ ] thing in
in Arizona Arizona I thought we're doing
it June Chicago theater and Ryan
Bobby Lee Santino and me we're doing
three big cities
yep that's gonna be so much fun you have
no idea that to me like what like
everyone makes money you know it's
always about money how do I don't give a
[ __ ] about any of that how fun would it
be if you Tom D'Elia Rogen brine me I'll
host that [ __ ] I don't there's
no ego from me I don't give a [ __ ] on
the new
I'll host it I don't care if any I would
pay you retire or you'll do 20 minutes
and you'll phone maybe you can go back
to that same market a week later correct
I don't but correct the thing is again
you're with your agent I'm with it my
idea Brian's we're the same agent but
the it's it's like boxing these
promoters give him it and it prevents
greatness from happening it really I
don't get it because we have the control
if my if I call my agent
now hey man I want to do Bert Tom D'Elia
Brian Santino and D'Elia and he's like
do you know I probably want to work on
my bike [ __ ] you know I promise
everybody has different drawers so then
the money gets split up differently
right that's the problem hold on this is
my thing with all that doing one of
those like White Collar Comedy Tour
which you know which they did back in
the day with Ron wide and [ __ ] all
the boys you got to put money the side
and realize it's bigger than that yeah
you know like it's bigger than that
I have app for the game I'm a prediction
that what's gonna happen we know that
what's going on with this thing we're
all pulling down dates for right now 30
days and then we can see where
scheduling and but I and we all and all
of us have big fall tours planned I mean
everyone's got a big fuel and falls
against my Europe I think I thought I do
I have an Asian tourists alone against
Allah cool I don't know and this would
never happen but what would be cool is a
huge arena tour at a comparable ticket
price meaning not we know letting the
economy get back on its feet for a
season and and giving people or wanted
gonna want to go out and I think if if
we could come together and find like a
great lineup that it doesn't have to be
all of us at once it can just be people
in different cities that can do
different cities East ten guys and you
don't know what city but yeah yes for me
I had the call in sick to work show this
was the greatest [ __ ] show I play at
the Comedy Store
yes sir those you don't know I planned I
could talk to both you guys you guys
both on it
I plan to call in sick to work so I
brought it bad branding with the
coronavirus going on but I want to
rethink the branding I used to do it on
the road all the time it was awesome I
would go into a city I do radio at 8:00
a.m. I drink all
at 10 a.m. I'd hop out I'd go straight
to the club bar doors would open at 9:00
show up at 11 do a show it was the most
fun he's done and then every one day
drinks and it's [ __ ] it's the funnest
shows I've ever done him I was so into
it so we just set it up with a store
released tickets a week outs is gonna
sold out immediately no one even knew
the lineup the lineup was [ __ ] insane
burr Jim Jefferies you too Sebastian
Maniscalco jo koy Tom Segura Norma
Donald Norman Donald's still texting me
going bro are we still doing this I mean
it was it was and that's by the way
Whitney Cummings
Chris D'Elia there was it was this most
insane [ __ ] line up and and that in
my head I get excited to be on those
shows mm-hmm because you look at it you
go as a ticket holder you got to see
that and go what kind of show do I get
to see today
exactly like not only will I see like
D'Elia come out and [ __ ] with Brian on
stage or or but I'll see Norman Donald
come out and and [ __ ] did you see his
coronavirus set it's not on viral notion
it's a bad
once again about branding but um it's
he's but it's it's I mean it would have
been so epic and then it's just you know
what this I did I did so much you know
my have a marketing brain like promo
brain
and I'm promoting this special hey big
boy screaming right now in Netflix but
like I had so many plans of like how to
get in front of this and really allow
people to find it yeah this is it it
gets real dark he calls it
because we watch it how long is it the
fitness is recognized for five minutes
oh let me see it I love
but on the way here I got really ill
he's the best dude I love you yeah it's
it's I don't wanna everyone should go
find it so go he's just so good man he
came backstage at the store one time and
it was like me and I was like me Rogan
Burt it was just a bunch of people that
all would command attention if they were
the person in the back and he showed up
and everyone shot the [ __ ] up
I mean like everyone Joe takes hail off
of a pen I think norm sober and normal a
judge got there Joe and he's like oh
it's a vape pen hey mine it was like was
marijuana non-exact Joe goes had this
really strong stop normally puts it down
he goes every tell you story about Bill
Clinton he has jokes
I've told jokes in his on on like he
hears the best jokes just the best jokes
I put it no lie in this bed I called
Stanhope one time I don't like to like
try to set up a joke that I tell him
this but I'm gonna tell you what joke it
is but like I had a joke in this special
that was this coming this current one
right now I that was a big boy which was
like my white whale I called Stanhope
one morning hey what are you doing he
goes I'm drinking a vodka and a
grapefruit vodka and grapefruit juice
I'm just trying to think of goofs that's
not wise I go what do you mean goofs he
goes I don't know he's like I'm I don't
know I'm trying to write a knock-knock
joke and I go really
he does yeah I mean we're as funny as
those guys were right like we're great
comics we got to be able to write
knock-knock jokes and we started talking
then we ended up talking about nor
McDonald and he thinks nor McDonald
punked him one time his nor McDonald
gameís shout out and he's never met nor
McDonald and so then I get in women or
McDonald rabbit hole and norm has his
joke I've told it before I won't tell
again about meeting his neighbor all
jokes nor folks were like old school Joe
he could he could write senator punch
and I'm old school joke and I got
obsessed
with an with come I was like I can do I
can do what I can do I'm gonna do what I
do for every special on this press are
gonna hear stories about my kids my wife
me being a bad dad
a [ __ ] everything's gonna eat all the
stuff sex so hand me a [ __ ] jokes I'm
[ __ ] joke everything all this should I
do
and I but I was like I wanna I want to
write it I want to write a joke or if
another comic hears that they're gonna
go oh [ __ ] that's that guy walks into a
bar and I and I did it and I was just
you know you rising especially it's on
this special you know when you write a
joke and you're like you can know how
you can't pays it you've been doing
press write is their thing no preps shut
down everybody I'm supposed to be big
pressed toward out in New York here and
everyone's no studio audience no no
guest is anything we're still you know
tell us a little bit can we expect this
special oh yeah yeah what that work how
much this press when you do if it's like
more than any anyone likes us like spurt
yeah anyone anyone who's gonna like what
I do
yeah is listening to this yeah and I
think it's not saying when you do it
it's all like what is your press tour
who are you gonna do I want to know and
how much I don't even mean any
difference at all it does if you do bar
stool which is our demo I do bar stool
there's you know my McAfee is a big one
well Pat Mac these the biggest Pat
McAfee is like I know that somebody had
told me that bro yeah let me to do it
and that's my good friend your good
friend to I love that yeah look at eat
anytime I have anything that takes
package podcast huge way bigger than us
dude way beyond the three of us in
football he's in sports he texted me the
other day and he goes he goes so our
sport chatter is gonna be a little low
any interested in flying out to Indiana
this week how did I'm it [ __ ] yeah you
should do it I'd go I'd go hang with him
have you been to set right yeah so it's
in Indy and he has it's in it's in
downtown it's like a Rogen compound it's
a Rogen compound but it's in downtown
Indy he opens up the garage you walk in
and it's like studio basketball court
[ __ ] podcast Bay where shoot just
show upstairs Murch like he
us figured it out he's the guy who was
on barstool he played professional
football he's upon her pro baller not a
big deal
pro baller plays with [ __ ] you know
the best guys in the world as far as
golf and do that he is the best everyone
loves them so the biggest names then I
felt go on a show they talked to him
first he's an amazing commentator so he
does a college football for ESPN he's on
he's on go on first take who go on wake
up in the morning or the [ __ ] it is he
does all of it good friend he's the best
he's a friend and he used to be a
hardcore partier now he just smokes weed
and just he did the announcement oh did
you see that for the Pelican for the
pelicans and like I mean change the game
he's he's a he's a real funny I think a
lot of those punters are funny
interesting but I mean that outfit oh my
oh and he's like WrestleMania my
favorite people I didn't know who he was
so he said so Tim when I got to Indiana
they said Pat McAfee wanted you to do a
show and I go I don't know who that is I
don't know you don't I was like wait you
know how it is everybody wants me to had
a hot cast so I'm like I'm not doing a
podcast in Indiana but I got I just got
here and I got a bunch of other [ __ ] to
do and was the big and then you told me
that he's an amazing guy and I'm like
whoa that's my boy you know Pat McAfee
ago okay he's so talented it told me
he's so [ __ ] talented I told him one
time I was like pretty confident that
with very minimal training I could be a
competitive field goal kicker in the NFL
Oh [ __ ] I've lost it and then bird
caught wind of it what's your field okay
oh just upon a putter everybody goes to
pro ball is oh it's about explosive
explain to me what up honor what makes a
good punter and what the
responsibilities explosive the putters
you know they can control you know where
the ball goes
yes see distance height soso height so
you don't want hiccup dream pulling you
guys can get down then get half McAfee
Kicks soccer ball a hundred and
twenty-five miles Pat Mackey kick a
soccer ball and it'll should come up
he's the Freak yeah yeah BK that's good
yeah just see what this is nice shot
yeah
know that no he kicked yeah watch this
yeah that's it why don't you kick some
my soccer ball 124 miles per hour and by
the way he did this he also light up
guys you ever seen him is his highlights
of Jesus you've seen the highlights of
him hitting guys in the NFL oh yeah
bring up that chin
he put helmets on people he's like a
Japanese fighter pilot in World War two
you know he [ __ ] he's got he's got
explosive power explosivity kickers do
ya see that's one thing he told me so
you know what the difference to me in US
and I said no what and he goes
explosivity yeah he goes I have that's
why I think Joe could get me a legit
field goal kicker yeah we play
basketball and he's [ __ ] good man
this is by the way this is a placekicker
field goal kicker punter that's and look
at he also feel you also did some
kilcullen Orla bow dude him lightness
dude up the best or is on sidekicks
what's this big right he's not take it
to the house yeah just lasted about time
peace girl oh yeah guys like that guy
alpha guys like that they get who they
want come on punishes you don't watches
no helmet to help hey leave me post-op'
they're lucky they may get food on the
plane okay but he's different
hey punters doc really nope
dude look I won one time I feel go kick
on see you missed the game-winning field
goal you know happen to him what sound
the back the plane to get fed that day
yeah they don't go through the same [ __ ]
we go through now Pat's different these
different cuz he's pack that's just
watch yes who else
look at this guy's still scored but
still I think punter has got to be the
funnest job because they're this
you just the gayest but it's Superman
yeah he he was not scared to but here's
the thing be he's he's up he's cut from
the same cloth he was a really good
punter he's a he he's a so he does stand
up that's he used to he did he really
his very first he's so stupid
he's walking like a burger it's time to
stand up one shot a special from 3,000
people she's huge fall yeah he does have
a special Brenda you'll play because I
released it on YouTube and you know what
it's not bad because all it is is its
locker room Joe sure it's just his
lockers expands if there's a lot of guys
I think I've drawn a ball here you
[ __ ] quarterback in for a touchdown
but you know really there's a lot of guy
it would have been that guy selling
boats who plays a lot of guys the NFL
and call you this bill on site here in
the locker rooms you gotta realize it's
all roasts
uh-huh it's roasting I noticed that so
football players I noticed that a month
more than any other [ __ ] I think are
the most socially adept and also the
funniest because they're always around
each other it's a team sport they're
always [ __ ] with each other so the
football players I know I'm bond exactly
but they also have high social
intelligence great senses of humor
totally can [ __ ] with you themselves
yeah but their self-deprecating shows
funny dude is about Quran like all these
guys yeah anytime at Barnes you know
Matt Barnes Matt Barnes is great more
Sanchez is gorgeous yeah I did Good
Morning America with him one time it's
little things like I was like saying
Hewes teach me how to throw and I and I
and I'm like okay you know because I did
she goes that's a good release actually
it's good I go no I'm a very good
athlete he goes take it easy now
it's little details like that where you
go you understand the language you get
the landmark was one the first times
where marks good buddy I wanted because
if I tell astray but mark was gonna
throw my other girls don't like him
right that that's not a trick eva
longoria he did forever and then any
girl you bring is gonna like him that's
right while you learn at the heart so
yeah here's this place in dana point
right and he goes do i having this party
come over first time I heard it Molly I
go over there
my cellphone I go do you not like you my
cellphone you gotta get and he's like
dude you're my boy but you gonna give
yourself one of my all right I get there
well when I say the most gorgeous people
I've ever seen in my life I'm like what
are we doing
yeah take my cell phone yeah [ __ ] yeah
hey take my wife - can she put her in a
bag look at big won a Heisman that
doesn't even look real
yeah and and by the way and again a
great guy and a funny guy intelligent
guy so they and the cutest kid you've
ever seen in the world sure the cutest
kid sure and super athletic for three
sure he's got a loser
some people have it all guys so yeah
it's funny yeah I I'm in a bad mood you
know what's crazy is that this okay this
is gonna sound somewhat egotistical like
we look at him when we go he's got it
all right gorgeous he's there's a guy
probably in Ohio going and Bert's got it
all man you gotta shoot higher sure my
wife says I'd like to wear a very tight
green sweater like that somehow I don't
think I yeah I don't know if that would
I should do that I should wear that with
a football
you're silly enough though when Seconal
yeah but you're skinny though your face
with that looks like a st. Patty's Day
look dude Saint Patty's see yeah my
birthday week see no Patty's is canceled
yeah everything's canceled they were
parade go not happening oh hey guys if
you're looking for something to do the
st. Patty's Day spend it with me hey big
boy on Netflix have a beer every time I
touch my face I'll watch it tonight
I probably shoot it at Cleveland and the
Agora Oh Cleveland [ __ ] great when
Anna did Rover another great radios
clovers great Rover people warned me
about Rover
they're like he'd be a little nasty know
who's fantastic group of dudes oh
they're all [ __ ] they're all [ __ ]
over already get his homework
yeah so like his question and I get done
it I'll do this some of the best radio
I've ever done he goes yeah so when I
got
this in this trailer just to be fair
play it just skinny Europa don't don't
play sound one of my jokes that it was a
putting here got memed [ __ ] like that
joke about my wife I wanted to have sex
with her because she was sick and she
was like I don't wanna get you sick I
was like well practice safe sex yeah
she's like you're gonna work on them I
was like no doggy style seat coffin to
the wall the this is the skinniest I've
been in my adult life
how do I do so skinny just for the
special rubber look at this no you don't
play audio I'll give you [ __ ] you do the
whole special with your shirt off
yeah yeah look at the skinniest I felt
[ __ ] ripped I don't rip where you
felt ripped
I felt [ __ ] ripped and it went great
when you feel like that here turn up the
audio you can hear the you can hear this
is the joke thick I'm definitely upset
with Berwick it's just like I don't want
to get you sick I was like we'll
practice safe sex
she's like you are doggy style see you
cough into the wall holiday let's hit
this longer by the way do you watch when
do you watch your own specials do you I
just saw myself ghost biting like you
ever give someone sandwich you made them
and then they gonna take a bite you go I
just when I watch my special I start
doing the act I just started doing that
I've never done that with a sandwich but
that's a lot about how do you wanna know
one word Jesus he doesn't know why he
sees pie he really doesn't that pies
nice I do that with kissing scenes I was
watching a movie called name of the Rose
with my dad when I was probably 10 years
old and they start making out and I'm
sitting next to my dad and I just start
ghost making out like well porno must be
exhausting dude I saw I was just telling
someone the other day I saw Rocco and
svet raucous parties in Savannah Samson
I've never seen that one father it is
the most massive
Savannah's San [ __ ] [ __ ] really and
I said Tom I said I halfway through it I
found myself swallowing
like just please and then and then when
he goes alright less time to [ __ ] I both
of me and her looked at each other in
the eyes she's in the porn and I'm here
I'm going we don't even [ __ ] there she's
a she's a [ __ ] yeah I am I knew her a
little bit oh yeah did you take her
first spin test drive I did not but but
I did not but I did know her and he was
I think broke her in the legend is yes
he broke her and yes and he did the
crazy face [ __ ] oh yeah and he goes
like this and I guess then she keep
going just when he went good now you are
in porn
oh wow Vanna is actually somebody who I
found to be not not only quite normal
and put together but also she had like a
real estate business she was in a lot of
vineyard yeah Vineyard she had a [ __ ]
vineyard she's a businesswoman she had a
she had a wine yeah my bus driver Ron is
pitching to me okay it's like all right
now he's a black dude he's like alright
here's the deal okay one of your promos
you get Christy Mack out here and you
shorter porn with me [ __ ] Christy
Mack and I was like okay that's not
gonna benefit me as a promo and he goes
oh just like what a good guy you are
that you paid her salary to [ __ ] me and
I was like I don't think that's how it
works right we just hire out he's like
you gotta ask I asked you to shoot hey
do you is your Starbucks bit on this
special that's the one I was talking
about yeah that's the one I love there's
my favorite joke dude sawed the copy
stored it's it's like the best it's the
best bit that I've ever done in my life
it's better than the machine in my
opinion it's like I'm like in love with
this bit and by the way I it's so funny
because I I took it and I not to like
get away to inside baseball but I wanted
it to be earlier I'm a big fan of Dave
Chappelle's kick her in the [ __ ] joke
and I'm more importantly I'm a fan of
all replaced that joke because he just
got me early he got me early so you have
to do right yep because Netflix I spoke
with them they were say
in at 28 minutes people shutoff so a lot
of people save all their best [ __ ] at
the end you should put at the front most
your [ __ ] should be at the front so you
captivate the audience because no matter
who you are Dave Chappelle bill burr
Bert Kreischer Tom Segura Chris D'Elia
they're gonna stop after 28 minutes so
they're gonna get it your vibe in the
first twenty eight D'Elia told me that
when I did secret time I had it stressed
out I had this this ziplining joke that
I had was closing with it [ __ ] it
murdered it murdered so hard
[ __ ] when in doubt spread them and I
said that's the clue it's the closing
line it's a perfect way to close a
special I have it at [ __ ] in I started
it like 45 minutes goes and leads into
it breaks out to the hour and I'm
sitting backstage to the store and
Thalia is sitting Aires with Eliza and
he's like he's like hey congrats on the
Netflix special it's like oh thanks give
me a heads up then I'll watch him past
30 minutes so if you got a joke you like
I put it up front
did that just it wasn't Chris going hey
here's how the algorithm
it was just Chris saying hey I had a
closure that no one ever heard paranoid
yeah Chris Chris talks about it where
people from one of his specials on that
I forget not man I ain't never even
another one he goes I saved all my [ __ ]
Diani it was people a reference to be in
Mackey looks good man but he's like oh
you didn't you didn't get to the meet I
heard him say that to me I took all my
[ __ ] that secret time and I put
anything that got a big laugh went in
that first 30 all of it I put a jammed
everything and I mean even chopped bits
up and I was like [ __ ] it and I closer
started it like 22 minutes smart and I
was like oh good to know but why not do
you know why not dude I'll tell you
right now that because you know I might
do it on when you're on the road and
you're doing an hour you know
roast different no no but they're saying
that but I'm saying you could do let's
say let's say Burt just did 30 of
complete [ __ ] savagery work yeah then
you have another 30 go on tour with and
you build off that 20 million dollars to
do 30 minutes though so like no no no
but doesn't Chappelle gets so then this
one I said I was like alright so I'm
gonna take I'm gonna take what murders
throw it upfront but then I was like I
was having a hard time following that
Starbucks bit because it was just
getting on yeah just a huge applause and
so
but what was cool and I would say this
every comic is take that take your
closer throw it up tip what that is your
first day of the challenge and you will
watch to the rest of your [ __ ] learns
how to step its game up you just start
knowing like you start seeing weaknesses
in everything we're actors in it too
like Quentin Tarantino said that the the
Christopher Walken scene with Dennis
Hopper and through a manse it's the best
scenes ever written it's the perfect
scene I think it's the greatest scene of
motion because I'm so [ __ ] you see
I'm talking about where Christopher
Walken is his mafia guy yes you know
what I'll take that and and he said yeah
and he said that that that scene was
unfortunately placed it was AI couldn't
follow it you can't follow certain but I
heard louis c.k say this before he says
if you're a young comic I always took
this are you just put your best [ __ ] at
the front and everything else is gonna
catch up cuz you're gonna work on that
bro I gotta take if you're not a polish
comic take your best joke they usually
say for your closer put at the front and
the rest your shits gonna catch up I do
that got I got today I get to the point
where I was like I was going through the
set and going like god damn stuff that
you used to kill like I have this bit
about having a buying a gun and I there
was a part of it they just murdered and
I was like [ __ ] get rid of it I kid I
I got because you needed that front part
to be so good yeah you're like [ __ ]
let's trim the fat let's start with a
brand new job let's and and that I'm
it's a cool way of doing comedy drink
that is so good man you don't realize
how much fat there is even as you click
code specials this for you this is my
fourth my fourth I did comfortably damo
Comedy Central in 2009 I did the Machine
which no one saw on on Stone Showtime
but I had the machine story in it and it
went viral and then I did and then
because of that I was this secret time
then they bought the machine the
machines on Netflix see your times on
Netflix and then hey big boy I'll be my
fourth and then I gotta be honest with
you you know what I think would be cool
I don't know if this is gonna be
possible but I would love to like
transition to what I'm doing into a
sitcom at some point like maybe like
I'll do one more special careful and
then all the stuff that you write put it
in a sitcom and just live in LA [ __ ]
do the road
don't pours aggressor I'm up touring
[ __ ] aggressive that's awesome some
private Joby you'll be you'll be waiting
on a double yeah you'd be up at five in
your workers and then you won't to stand
up so sheer pretty take nine of years
best-case scenario you want the best
case scenario yeah you'll take nine
months off and you'll have a week off
every three weeks and you'll have a week
off now you want to say this because
they have no idea I have no idea I just
showed up on frightened by the way that
add to that you like these great kids
not bad really good they they got a
boxing Bob now keep keep keep this and
rogamus said I want you to do your I
want you to do your TV show I want you
to drive now where do you live great I
know I know exactly where you live now
let's just say suits got healthy if it's
just Anna Manhattan Beach or down an NB
Culver City oh sure sure yes
no yes what's the matter has CSI any of
those one hours a lot of them but
doesn't matter listen Joe could be in
Valencia either way you enjoy that
because that's gonna be a good Drive now
I'm need you to wake up at I know I know
4:45 news you get get out I need you
have the door at 5:15 now listen up will
you'll be in makeup you also have dear
podcast and keep writing your standup
but it's how the people are the robbers
the show be huh it was to shawl right oh
you wanted to be a writer I will see you
never will see you never show goes away
that's what happened but nine months cuz
he's writing he's gonna come over the
other episode back then I'd take five
years off you stand up and we'll all get
way to come back and then come back I'm
back didn't didn't uh school get
canceled well so school didn't get
canceled with the we didn't shoot the
final apple shot 21 episodes we are not
shooting the 22nd episode because of the
coronavirus but listen you know and I
had I love my cast I love my show I have
a great time I'm not in any way saying
this I'm saying people don't realize how
much work it is he asked him then I got
to come to the state of the [ __ ]
podcast and I'm late every day you can't
make it it's it's so hard and then I'm
trying to stand up at night never mind I
like what I'm doing right now dude
in the Travel Channel shitbird when you
have the kind of you're able to make the
kind of money you're making and and do
what you're doing as a comic I don't
think there's any better job in the
world
look it's the greatest third question so
just knows that if it ain't broke don't
know it's funny our mutual friend a
visual friend goes he was I was a mark
Normand goes dude I was on the road with
Burt he was out to leave after three
weeks yeah I guess I learned have to go
home I go cuz there were time out who'd
be the funds go on the road with and I
got I feel like Burt Burt you know
really be great he goes dude that yeah I
think he said two weeks of two weeks
Isaacson you know I can't and marchings
all the time yes I can he's he was like
to go home
he was he was one of the funniest humans
to be with I run so I run in a fast clip
I don't realize it's a lot of times like
the way my brain operates it's very like
I don't know if it's like panic inducing
but like like I'll get up a workout and
then like I work out every every morning
usually I work out every day on the road
because I just if I don't I feel like I
don't get the toxins out and I feel like
I'm gonna [ __ ] up yeah I feel cloudy and
so I barely worked it worked out with
Marcus which meant we were there was a
lot of day drinking involved were flying
a lot and we get to the airport and I'd
be like I'd be like I just grabbed us
both a beer and he'd be like oh are we
back at it and I'm like come on mark I
dude I love that
getting someone egging someone in to get
no drink in the more come on man TT
doesn't sound a big last note lime mark
it's just one just one and then we got a
we got him addicted to ambien ambien and
then we lost the ambient a little and a
drink and he says fall asleep wakes up
he was huh how it's amazing huh that was
amazing
I've ever had and it was me and my
cameraman was with me he's so funny and
I even trying I'm not why so funny
so dude I've never heard his brick I uh
his
joke or not joke but his bill bird story
no what is it
so he goes he was just just like he goes
to like in LA we all look up to Bill
bird he goes and I and I see him at the
cellar and he's but he's kind of by
himself and I go burn let's grab a drink
NES let's get the [ __ ] out out he goes
like he goes I've never met him and
burgos they said that [ __ ] yeah let's do
it
he was so he didn't do this week is
around a bar and you know I don't know
they got a little awkward and a songs
planning he goes you know he says
something he goes you know they say the
n-word in this song and he told Burt
burn knows music verse obsessive you
know and it's a some like ac/dc some
classic song and Burt goes oh my burst
drinking us what do you say because they
say the n-word in this song in burgos
the [ __ ] you talking about and he goes
huh replay it back and burr I guess just
tears into him about it and mark says
he's like whoa so he goes I'm so
embarrassed cuz I thought I thought I
was like he was I forgot his wife's
black so we get into he goes he's like
yelling at me and he goes and then it
just like fizzles out I leave he's like
[ __ ] because I panic I leave yours
next morning we're doing press together
and I don't want to go I call my jeans
like do that one I don't want to [ __ ]
do this thing you're gonna be fine
Berbers a good guy he goes there and
Burgess completely was like what's up
like everything was all oh yeah that's
so good I got a call from Bill I'm on my
way to the fight companion I'm buying
wine and cheese he must have known I was
on my way and he and I just get a call
and it's bill I go hey he goes I just
want you to know I can feel the cloud of
self-doubt taking you over as you make
your way to the fight companion and she
said bunch of dumb [ __ ]
thank you [ __ ]
he's all yeah that scares me at the
comedy score story he's never dying
thing to me he's just like I'll call you
out it's like it's like a legend walking
through he is to me isn't imminent I
think he's the best comic working though
depends what you like yeah I love him
because we went to
Sceptile game together and he goes what
you guys doing nothing to do you called
me good you wanna go an excel game I was
like [ __ ] yeah so I go gets close yeah
really close I didn't know that we have
a podcast together Oh Bert toys so we go
down to the we go down to the accessible
key and I'm super gregarious like I love
meeting fans like a fan recognized me I
get excited also and I love taking
pictures that is not Bill Bert Bert good
guys hey man I don't want to be that guy
then bill goes then don't and walk away
[Laughter]
I recognized and people aren't
recognizing bills he's got a hoodie on
and a hat on and hide I know he's not
trying to hide it the Sun it's really
bad he didn't want to burn
he put sunscreen all over so he's got a
hoodie and a hat on and he's eating he's
eating the pizza and we're walking
through and people are like the Machine
I'm like what's up and they're like oh
dude I'm a big fan oh [ __ ] yeah and so
what bird leans over he goes hey stop
matching their energy you're getting
more excited than they are which is
making this turn into a frenzy yes Jose
just say hey how you doing it keep
walking okay
dude we yeah I love Bill he's one of the
funniest my favorite bill bird story is
this is how quick his brain works right
I'm certain this isn't a bit of his but
we're driving in a car one night one day
and I see a van old conversion van I go
I go
you know bill bill loves nostalgia like
old things old so I go I hope it
wouldn't matter how cool those were we
were kids how great with conversion vans
with the captain seats he's like yeah I
go whatever happened then he goes that's
a branding issue he's not writing a joke
because it's a branding issue this is a
branding issue yeah a couple guys rape a
couple kids and some vans and now you
can't drive a van around then he goes
Burt same thing with rollerblades
they were fun for a summer next you know
a couple gay guys were gay we're rolling
it is he's not trying to be funny happy
but like but
the thing I like about Bill is Bill wool
Oh bill we'll find a part of you that's
funny that you don't know is funny yeah
and then he'll point it out and it'll
enjoy it's like we go to lunch one day I
don't I if I see someone who I don't
think English I will say the English
word like four times like napkins
napkins napkins napkins napkins napkins
like just I don't know why should I get
it yeah and Bill's like he gets it man
napkins I go hot sauce hot sauce we're
at this part with his chicken restaurant
and then they come and they go are you
done with everything and I guess I went
like this I go yeah I'm done who the
[ __ ] do you think you are Archduke
Ferdinand yeah I'm done but I didn't
realize I do it I just go oh yeah I'm
done he'll correct you too I remember a
conversation with a backlink on me store
and he said some I go oh yeah you're
correct the [ __ ] you because I went and
went yeah it's like people sign up the
by a pitbull like you're gonna deal with
pitbull probs yes it's any dog just show
say pitbulls but it's any document get
any done yeah all right what you're
wearing your jumpsuit you guys you look
like a you look like a mechanic from a
musical yeah I went because I wear a
jumpsuit like Chappelle wears by work
before special came out and I wore it
and I was like I love jumpsuits so I
wore it from John Varvatos and I went
and everyone's kind of clown on me and
you know Tony Hinchcliffe Rogi and
everyone yeah and then burr walks and I
was like man this is the worst and he
says his line right you look like a
mechanic from a musical and then Rogan
the boys jumped on me and burst stuck up
for me I was like how [ __ ] yeah dude he
said something like oh if you could
[ __ ] get away with you'd wear that
[ __ ] so he looks [ __ ] fine he's he
co-signed I'm like yes shut your [ __ ]
mouth
dude he's an interesting like and he
would he would not like hearing this but
he's a very sensitive interesting
thoughtful guy who really cares about
people but he would not like hearing me
say that he has that but usually tell
you in this hitman Rogan are the reason
I got the reason I'm where I am today
and I might get sad about a million
things I wish I could pinpoint different
times in my career where Joe kind of
pointed in the right direction number
one number one is him
I had to tell the Machine onstage oh wow
him doing oh I told her on his podcast
and and he said this is one of the
greatest stories I've ever heard
you got to tell about sage I said it's
not a story he goes no it is now from
now on I wish I got the audio of this
I'm sure it's I'm sure I'm inflating
into my head someone's gonna find goes
for now on he is only to be known as the
Machine and when he goes onstage shout
the machine until he tells it I went to
Columbus that weekend and they were
shouting the Machine and I was like guys
guys guys it's not it this is the
beginning of the cult of death squad
remember that early early stages but
there are my guys I'm not gonna tell him
this kid in the front row goes dead so
Columbus is like a big hot bed for
podcast yeah kid the front row goes hey
Bert man tell it we understand it's not
gonna be funny right guys
like his we got to work on it if it's
gonna get good oh wow and I went what
the [ __ ] kind of community i involved in
that's number one number two he calls me
Road and calls me one time I'm riding
[ __ ] motorcycles through rice paddies
in Vietnam high as [ __ ] drunk right I
mean I'm doing travel team I'm on the
flip flops tits and road-crossing he
goes what you doing I saw him drunk as
[ __ ] that's high and I'm running running
motorcycles through rice paddies in
Vietnam and he just starts laughing and
he goes this is who you are
[ __ ] Travel Channel this is who you are
and if you're not talking about this on
stage you are wasting your talents as an
artist [ __ ] Travel Channel get away from
it come back to stand up I was like he's
right yeah and then my wife called and
she's like what you are not the machine
you're a father of two get the [ __ ] off
that motorcycle and then cut to I'm
doing my second my last season of birth
I did birth Concord reboot abhart
conquer I've been on a Travel Channel
for nine years I'm backstage with Vern
rogue and I walk in and I guess I don't
know if I said something what you TV
this is of five years ago okay five
years ago almost it yeah probably
almost exactly and i said i don't know
if i said something TV ish you know
about like i don't know what I said but
he goes they Brogan just in like and I
got like I can't keep it in anymore him
embargo him in your show sucks
uh-huh and they're like what do you like
it TV star is that what you want to be
like a like a Travel Channel host like
the way
said it was like they're like you're not
you're better than that you know that
right and I was like guys guys I was
like guys I got a you know I got a
family I got and they just Burgess goes
what's your not and I go what he was how
much money do you need to make a year to
pay your bills tell me the number and I
was like and I told them the number was
number was low at the time I assumed my
number is the exact same number we know
today oh yeah we don't have it we don't
really buy it but honest yet but it's
it's still big number yeah and and burn
Rogan they're like yeah you can get that
from podcasting and I remember them
being like hey focus on your podcast
focus on your podcast you know will help
you get guest will all be on your
podcast they're like get and then you
can get monetized for your podcast and
I'll tell you you can make that from
podcasting and stand up there like get
the [ __ ] away from Travel Channel when
those two dudes [ __ ] that's me from
day one he's been saying [ __ ] acting
just to stand up and punch of course I
never listened and problems yes yeah in
podcast problem is now you know I never
listened then you get a TV show and then
I just sold another show and then I
think I sold another show usually the
problem is that right now no I'm not
bragging the problem is that you when
you're trying not to do something
doesn't mean they want you trapped into
this thing and you have to kind of go
you have to sit back and go I'm a comic
first and foremost the just others you
came out of it act like you're an actor
I know but I like stand-up more stand-up
is so how much fun did that that's the
promise to the comedy store like I was
saying that some below-the-belt Showtime
I'm saying how I think I took it for
granted cuz I was on the road for like
12 weeks in a row either kinda [ __ ]
break think Corolla comes and you can't
do it it's like I'm going [ __ ] crazy
oh yeah everything is it true that all
the restaurants are closed in the bars
LA County LA we're in Santa Monica's so
the restaurant across street and
everything's closed in you can take out
and they took the break
dude I need these
I saw him t-shirt the other day I went
oh well my bottom teeth are starting to
come
yeah that's what my bottom teeth went
you know what let's look like the New
York skyline is nobody's disciplining on
them serious party like let's party my
bunkie like Oh mosh pit no no yeah like
the coronavirus separate your sense
right they're separate that's where
candid come in candor clear aligners you
don't have to go to a doctor I had to go
to a doctor take a mold of my teeth into
that they do a 3d first of all the 65%
less than braces but they do it this
race into a 3d picture of your mouth and
then I guess your treatment is
prescribed remotely by a licensed
orthodontist it's not you six months
yeah all these dentists and it takes
just six months you start seeing results
way before then I hate a please send
this to me yeah learn more by Candice
process get compliments complimentary 3d
scan of your teeth at candid studio near
you it's simple
Frias way to get started so you ready to
get your teeth straight dude are you
fellas or ladies whatever you're a
purely $75 off the coat you later I'll
do it I'll do it
go to candy-coat calm slash fighter
that's candy coat calms ice fighter you
skilled fight over $75 off to get your
teeth straight candy coat calm slash
fighter I love I love Bert because me
and you were talking about it I think in
the belly room if you remember this
you're sober
I'm usually sober before I go on stage
yeah we're talking about ticket sales
because I find it so fast
do not get me started he has his Black
Mountain tickets like ticket sales cuz
they move my tickets I think from 20 to
25 and then from 25 to 30 and such it it
just you you're talking about a world of
difference we're like five dollars
whatever it's I studied under Tom Segura
so I this is one of my favorite it like
and by the way this in the tape but
there's a good story so I'm in Philly
right Tom's doing the truck Tom's doing
the truck he's doing $35 tickets suck it
down jargony room maybe $40 tickets I'm
doing $20 tickets at helium so guy comes
up to me and he goes he's like Burt let
me tell you something man
I'm always gonna be a [ __ ] fan you boy
Tommy charge him 40 bucks for [ __ ]
tickets
40 bucks I get 80 bucks for me and my
girl to go see this guy plus drinks
plus parking down at the truck and he
goes or I got you for 40 bucks I go I go
hey man thanks brother I called Tom I go
I go hey just give me I'm just giving
you a heads up man people are saying huh
you take a price are too high at Toms
like his time was that [ __ ] that guy
right so I go back I get on stage and
the guy I met is that talk to me is in
the front row and he's so [ __ ] drunk
him and his chick are ruining the show
did they had to within my first five
minutes
grab them physically drag them out and
the biggest fight ensued like the whole
time I go I'm raising my [ __ ] pig
yeah but Bert knows it cuz I was like
dude they want to do this I'm worried
about it I'm when you don't we in talked
tickets doctor Bert your armor what I
love I like the business of this too
look this is why I come from this so Joe
bill all those great stories about like
get away from Travel Channel I get away
from Travel Channel right I get fired
from I can go and and and I'm supposed
to do the big Funny or Die to remember
eyeball
they do eyeballing I got [ __ ] 12
dates on our belt I cleared my whole
calendar September didn't December I'm
empty I'm just doing oddball begin her
house torn down we're gonna rebound our
house my wife schedules a vasectomy I
got all this [ __ ] going on right
oddball cancels 12 dates I'm all of
those dates I [ __ ] why they canceled
because no one bought tickets they
didn't get a they never didn't get like
a proper headliner they had the people
that now are selling arenas weren't
selling event okay like fluffy and
Sebastian and so that's I mean that's
what I'm told and then of trying to get
fired from travels handle and I am just
I got nothing and I'm and I'm and I want
to sell tickets cuz I'm getting it right
the clubs at the time I was getting like
when I was gonna start up again I was
getting a $10,000 guarantee was my deal
and I was like I don't want its there's
no worse feeling than get asking for
money and then not making that money for
the club and knowing you just had their
month they can't I I just assumed and I
have said just don't give me what you
can give me yeah I don't I don't want to
[ __ ] you guys yeah cuz you're my
business next year too like you're how
I'm paying my mortgage next year and so
I that's what I got really Aileen
- I did a vlog and I started doing
Internet videos and I was like I was
like dude I kind of enjoyed it and I
enjoyed this weird kind of like
especially when you get ticket counts
you do a video you post it and then you
start seeing the it track or like
Cleveland do this one was so Cleveland
when we did this special we did Agora we
signed up to do five shows filming -
yeah filming - filming two shows we
signed up to do five shows and then I
said I want to show how much they're
gonna cost to film one more night thank
God I said that because on my second
show of the first night there was a
mustard stain on my pants I guess had a
[ __ ] hot dog in the bucking Babe Ruth
over here so I said I want to add two
more shows and they go okay just give me
a heads up telling me like over 7,000
tickets you got to move of Cleveland and
I was like okay so I [ __ ] batten down
the hatches and was like everything else
is sold I got him I got a focus on
Cleveland and by the way I had never
moved 7,000 tickets in a market that's
seven times tickets is I gotta take a
lot of [ __ ] tickets that be the most
and it was so much fun to do a video and
and find ways to market to Cleveland and
do it to Cleveland screams man it count
and then watched ticket sales grow and
go I'm fine in robocar overhead can I
hop on your show of course it was so
amazing that I started going men the
power of just you this is when I changed
my mind - I thought I remember in this
whole process of doing this for
Cleveland someone told me hey man you
want to go see Wilco tonight now go
wilcos in town and they're like yeah I
go I didn't know that oh [ __ ] no I can't
go him I promise to do something with my
wife and kids and then I was like [ __ ]
you Jeff Tweedy why wouldn't you let me
know you're coming in town like what and
then I thought I wonder if there's
people for us that love this show that
are sitting in wherever you are next
week no or next weekend but wherever
you're gonna be that goes that goes
Austin then sees on this show and then
the next weekend and you go man Austin
was a blast
he's like Oh Austin how do I know about
that and and it's the thing is you can't
it's not their responsibility to watch
every episode we do it's not their
responsibility to be on our Twitter
non-stop it's our responsibility to as
artists to let the people that want to
see us know where we're gonna be that
Jeff Tweedy story switched my brain and
I thought if Jeff Tweedy cared a little
bit and by the way I will say this out
loud
I think Jeff Tweety's heard this story
cuz him and Slater Kenny are doing a
tour and they did a funny [ __ ] video
about their tour and I guarantee you
that tour sold out immediately good and
but but it's our responsibility to sell
our tickets to our fans all these people
that like go I was just there sign up
for my mailing list you're like no your
mail
[ __ ] you mailing list yeah [ __ ] put
in your stories every single day [ __ ]
mention it every single day throw it in
if you do a funny video if a cop pulls
you over and you do a funny video you
just don't I got to move of Cleveland
and and by the way don't ever tell
people sold out ever ever [ __ ] ever I
always tell people I be humble and
that's one of the one thing that I
noticed maybe sell out we care if you
sell out they don't care we care you're
only doing not view but like we were
doing it for each other to go wow
someone sold out I don't give a [ __ ] if
Thalia knows that I sold out what I care
is that people always think you can get
a ticket to my show and just you don't
I'd like that selling out thing manner
or there's you don't see it creates the
man know the easier factors it doesn't
worry TMX okay good they can't buy a
ticket correct and that's they go they
gotta be on it no no do they know they
sell out trust me they know that sold
out they're trying to bind it all yeah
and especially when you there's no
better I mean preach I look at it like
like I did when I was doing this weekend
everything's sold out this weekend and I
had like tickets to move in on my second
show in Huntsville
I didn't hey guys or New Orleans
Batman Orleans Montgomery in Huntsville
I'm there all weekend
there are taste still available swipe up
if you want tickets don't go Norland and
puns mounds company are sold out but
only know it's like it's like it's like
you're not you're not its you're not
trying to sell anything to anyone you
just let it's like some people I think
see through that see gloating and then
and then you go but I got dancin I just
look at both sides I see both sides but
I'll tell you what for me
it you could see drew I did it a bunch
you know and it's cool if you got a tour
of date right added second show but like
I'll tell you what and we're talking
about these guys a lot bill burr I say
you ever look at your ticket counts and
he goes no and I said would aren't you
worried that like sometimes you'd be
light on the show and you'll and he just
goes part they all sell out and I went
oh I want to be that guy but that I want
to be that guy but that bill birth 30
gained 30 years deep in the game yeah
yeah yeah yeah if you ask Bill burr yes
Joe Road yes
you know Chapelle says you know first of
all so much of this is a result of the
internet yeah and you know he's come
along now in during social media when
you're younger than me but you mean you
remember you remember dude I remember
when the big boys weren't selling out I
remember the big boys were relying
always on local media and and I also
remember when there was no such thing
really as theatre accent stating never
there was everybody everybody was doing
clubs because it's just the way it was
it was yeah so that now there's this new
I by the way the fact that the Comedy
Store because the podcast has become so
huge more infamous again it was nothing
legend it was it was where people didn't
want to go and so you know realize he
changed so much in the past let's
suppose diligence which hey great it's
changed with you talking to Justin the
other day they've canceled over 7
million dollars just in March alone in
comedy gigs and life torn 7 million
dollars in March alone all the acts 7
million dollars here's what's crazy
about this point oh seven percent of all
comics in the world can sell tickets
point oh seven point oh seven out of all
the comics can sell to sell takes means
selling a weekend at a club theater I
see 0.001 where you're at it's a
different different level yeah but even
the to that yeah Justin tells me at all
the time we don't know III don't I know
I know I didn't come from that world but
I'm following bird I'm following time
following Chris Vaughn oh by the way
these are just my thoughts about my
thoughts about my ego looking looking
empty you remember when we were on
myspace Brian and we were like hold on I
was on myspace too you know but we were
been in my top a bird we were we were in
this group of like when Dane ruled the
world there's some danger to do a love
day I'm not [ __ ] on Dane there's
something nice to do that rubbed me
wrong
always always hey guys
Dane Cook here I got a big secret to
tell you guys I'm not gonna tell you
today I can't tell you yet but I got a
big secret coming tomorrow you guys hear
this you guys are gonna lose your mind I
felt like going like that [ __ ] work
though
but yeah I did but it always rubbed me
wrong so I was like hey man
this isn't your this is your ego talking
like this isn't this is kind of gross
how so because I know what was his
secret I never felt to hell you know
yeah like just like a [ __ ] sea and the
marina all the [ __ ] I'm doing he created
all this he the whole [ __ ] game you
said to hold my beer and then ran no no
I don't know if I was that close but
what I will say I will say I'm not even
remotely you know will say that like
that like a Dane Dane was a pioneer I'll
tell you what I'll tell you it was more
effective for me then I got a big secret
things and and I would say I'd say but
I'm saying listen don't say big secret I
would say I would he my dad called me
and going buddy do you know a guy named
Dane Cook and I go no and he goes he's
on the cover of USA Today and by the way
that was the shift when Dane like like I
remember calling the game he was the
first you can learn this stuff you
didn't like from him and apply that as
well you can go huh I didn't like this
[ __ ] I love this [ __ ] yeah but here's
the other thing about Dane I know every
what's this [ __ ] on Dane whatever I like
Dane he's always been great to me Gaines
always been ain't well still [ __ ]
crush up room dude dude you should Ryan
you remember hold on with that goeth got
that [ __ ] to the dance was
college dude he killed me he know he's
still but here's my watch him and be
horribly horribly something everything
we were doing he steals a [ __ ] you
understand people were bombing when Dane
was in that tank top there were still
comical doesn't prompt they would Dave
Attell would bomb louis c.k would bomb
that was how they did stand-up you would
bomb and bomb and you get a couple good
ones Danny's never [ __ ] mom strong
was Evel Knievel him in Dublin's
every
he sued him in Dublin's was watching
like watching the first caveman make
fire I couldn't speak I watched and I
with this he got me back into stand if I
wasn't doing competence but the calmly
store a few weeks yes I'm tell me how
you know what he's a real common it was
just crowd work he's a real cop don't
want to fall in four years the state I
watched him do the Boston Comedy Club
yeah I watched him do the Boston comedy
I was at that taping oh yeah I was a fan
no no as a friend I been new Dane back
oh you'd and aim for as long as I've
known bill you ain't sat me down in his
apartment he does not live on what do
you have opened my robe for Dane okay
never one for Dane Dane sat me down he's
to live in an apartment off of Fairfax
it was it's the old jhana the old
Kennedy compound there's money one of
those beautiful buildings I had ever
seen one of the most building up
beautiful apartments I've ever seen and
he was we went over to play guitars and
your [ __ ] go see a movie and he was
and he was just going over his computer
the whole time I thought that thought
that so anyway now I go what are you
doing and he goes oh dude clear let me
show you this is gonna change the game
you need to get a myspace profile and I
was like smart I was like huh by the way
I was like good luck you never even
catch me doing that [ __ ] yeah if I had
listened he answered every Eve every
anything I talked to him he said he said
I started noticing people were emailing
me and a lot of people and and I said to
myself if I if I start making a log of
these emails and letting people know
that I'm gonna be back there and that's
what he started doing sweet we got him
on the show we I've talked him the other
day I want to come on the show I'll tell
you what man if you think now think
about this right we're talking about
game changers know if you're thinking I
had anything even remotely to do with
Dane that's nothing that's nothing think
about Rogan what he did he broke the
[ __ ] game when he decided it's not
she Pearson they're all different no
compare my but I'm saying what what Dane
did was just as effective of Rogan oh
yeah you know no no right right so Dane
broke the mold Joe broke the mold dude
Schultz was breaking the [ __ ] mold
correct you guys broke the mold you and
you guys doing this podcast popped and
everyone was like dude fighter in the
kids getting doctor fighter in the kid
dot because like at the time
quieter comedian at the time cage
fighter dirty comedian it was earned
kick comedian two dudes doing a comprar
cast everyone was doing the solo mode
everyone was like it's autocracy no were
doing them but like me Joey Ari Duncan
uh everyone was doing the solo mode and
you guys showed up
that was a [ __ ] game changer do I
love I like I hope to god I live long
enough to read a book about what has
happened in comedy from like from what
comes I mean just my perspective of of
getting in and when I started I didn't
know people didn't do the road
no one did the road you lived in New
York where you lived in LA they just
didn't know that we just rode comics
there were road comics like like the
[ __ ] and and JJ medicine hat they
were road dudes and Kirk Nolan there was
a guy named oddly enough Jim Breuer
who's not the same Jim Breuer Road guy
all these road guys did did the road and
then you in New York comics who would
kind of do some like in Long Island and
new you and down the coast but they
weren't going in technically the funny
Mo's and then everything changed and
like David Spade would do Tempe improv
and I would see that no go oh wow then
they offer you to do the road you're
like because what happened is the Irvine
improv open like 13 clubs the funny
bones open like 20 Club and they started
blowing up the road I mean you're right
when you talk about [ __ ] theater
comics you go there was when we were
when we've started there was not joke
when bill burr how they'll tell you hey
hey Bert can ask this and this might be
super deep house sausage is made in
comedy but they booked me on this then
we can add this out it doesn't matter
but when they booked ground theater
tours right and you're like this is good
free blah blah Mike right cool man one
night in City I just like spent a few
nights in city learning city right get a
hangout meet the locals whatever I love
doing that then we go to theaters when I
like the numbers like oh dude this is
just an ego thing a lot of comics are
booked in theaters because their ego
money I would rather go to New Orleans
do six shows I'd rather do Atlanta do
six shows my mama way more money I get a
work on my craft I get a hangout in town
I don't have to take so many planes why
am i doing theaters they go what's a
good look Korea holding oh hold on
according to WHO you go well the other
- - I don't give a [ __ ] about what
people another comics let me um let me
do these comedy clubs do their I know
but you want you graduate towards
theaters ago no no you understand dude I
don't give a I want the most money
possible them as many reps as possible I
that's what I want to do I fought with
my reps so hard how do you how do you
make my my question for you because you
know days says like a [ __ ] this
is how the inside baseball I don't
explain how it works please do because I
don't get how how comics can go into one
unless you're Joe Ryan Chappelle how can
you fly in from one night in Atlanta New
Orleans and make the same money that
you'd make if you did five or six shows
yeah so so you do your first theater run
they offer it to you and they say just
so you know you gotta take a hit and I
say okay why am I doing this yes and
they go because it's it's it's a good
it's a good footprint it's what you want
to be seen if you can if you can make
the leap to theaters it says a lot for
you in the business of like of
television and movies is that you made
the jump to theaters because it's really
hard to get this guy who knows us as
club comics for our whole entire career
so these guys these guys right here have
been following us for nine [ __ ] years
right well first time I did Brogan they
were like oh I like that guy I'm gonna
go check out fighter in the kid oh now
there are my guys right they've been
coming to the clubs Columbus funnybone
[ __ ] date and funny bone Toledo funny
bone Miami improv Tampa and probably in
helium yeah put a bug in all these clubs
if you can make the leap to theaters you
then say I don't just have someone
that'll come to see me in clubs and and
is a fan of the club I have people that
will take make the move to theaters with
me
so when I go to theaters they will
actually it's out of it it's like a
different ticket buy for them to like go
to the theater I know it sounds crazy
but that's what they say so then you go
I go well I don't really give a [ __ ]
about that
I love clubs I'm a club comment and
they're like and they're like trust me
they they said trust me
my dad said [ __ ] them they don't know
what they're talking about he was like
dude stay in the clubs you're making
great money in the hubs so then you make
the leap to theaters and you go on sale
dude uh I'll be very candid Tom's raps
we're like you're making a big [ __ ]
mistake you can't fill theaters because
it's it's it's a it's a weird thing to
transition and there
we're trans pretty like hold on I can go
this marking cell whatever 14 to 2,000
tickets
you put me a theater I can sell 900 will
take I can watch a train 3500 Chicago
theater Chicago three weeks ins in a row
now you view itself if you get South
37,000 3700 tickets in Chicago in one
night you can do literally a month's
residency in Chicago and you would sell
every single show out why because well
because you're talking about a clubs
holds twelve hundred people thirteen
hundred people but if you're gonna move
thirteen hundred people in a night yeah
as opposed to over the weekend it's a
difference a different muscle so how do
you make money so let's use the let's
use the Wilbur as an example I think
it's a very safe example I hope
everyone's comfortable with me [ __ ] I'm
gonna do since I said but like numbers I
said an imaginary number I'll keep on an
imaginary numbers week week so you go
into Wilbur and you do one show you've
got to pay for the curtain you gotta pay
1214 it's 11 I think it's 1100 cable $20
tickets the first time I went into it
did a $20 ticket which is a very doable
ticket in Boston but it's you know
Saturday night they give you good
placement Saturday night you gotta
remember doing getting the breakdowns as
1900 borough pretty close I'm pretty
close on I can almost tell you the and
so so you I get the breakdown annex you
got a rent security arts you got to
write the curtain I remember it's so
expensive you register so you had to pay
for the staffing of everyone you had to
pay for rental of the lights you had to
pay for the rental of the mic the mics
can't like you had to pay for everything
because it's so fans no buts to
interrupt just so fans know when you go
to Cotton Club that's all cup it's all
covered it's all pay for not renting the
place none of that you get your pay for
your town you're paying for everything
because it's to drink minimum
yeah because housing minimum otherwise
they would just stay dark and they
wouldn't lose any money
okay kids but if you're gonna go in and
you're gonna say I'm into this so then
you do the first show and I and you're
like great me by the way I'm not great
on numbers but maybe you walk with like
twelve thousand dollars okay
yes right sellout and so I remember I
did that one show and then I was like
wow I went in the next time I did two
shows of the Wilbur and I was like cool
once again the numbers aren't
Kirra 24 grand I just remember 12 number
drop gram being the number for Friday
and Saturday
nope note for that great no for one
night one night two shows and I was like
great I'll walk with 20 24 grand and I'm
like this makes no sense
24 then I get my check and ice
astronomically higher then I go whoa
what happened and they said well you
already rented everything so that second
show that's all your money and you went
oh that's okay so then me so then we go
to the theater tour and we announce it
I think right we announce it like two
months out everyone text me Tom's reps
are like horrible idea you're not a
theater act you're never gonna be a temp
Tom's reps texted because they because
they have [ __ ] cuz cuz Berkowitz
loves me oh [ __ ] No
Andrews coolship Berkowitz's cool [ __ ]
but they just they're in my ear and it's
one of those things where they go if i
tec look I'm sorry guys
good it problem if they take but never
gonna give me trouble [ __ ] if they text
me and told me I wasn't gonna sell
theaters in there yeah and by the way
I'm friends with them I'm good with them
but also eat this dick yeah but but it
look they both have come I got a
complicated history that's guys so they
text me and they're like amen I don't
think this is a good fit you're not
doing the right clubs you're not doing
the right it's gonna be a hard ticket
sell a cell I don't think you doing our
theaters and so I'm like [ __ ] now I'm
nervous I'm in my head they want that
because if I don't sell theaters I'm
leaving my agents I'm going right to
them and they know deep down oh he can
sell [ __ ] tickets and theaters
I pray to God something goes wrong on
that day so that I can get this class
I'm sure they're playing that game and
so we go on sale and we sell at like the
first day we Brian Dorfman the guy I'm
working with now right I go in the
shower we go on sale at like at like
10:00 a.m. I get the shower at 10:07 my
wife comes in she goes Wilbur sold out
and now I'm going math I go oh I had a
second show and they're like they want
to add a second show I definitely have a
second show get out of shower I get my
bed Andrew Toms rep says amen Congrats
at the girl have a great tour and I was
like oh wow it's Andrews a [ __ ] solid
so theater is the money's if you can
sell to show skews ourselves the first
one covers your next ones where you make
ammonia so then CSL between really three
to three thousand takes in every market
to really make money on that and your
first year to run you're gonna go to
theaters anywhere from a thousand ten
maybe fifteens as big as you're gonna go
roughly maybe 17 like 18 I think is
maybe but we're not going to go too big
so the house in the 15 so then Berkowitz
texts me and he's like hey man Congrats
it looks like you gonna have a good
theater run you know both the solid
dudes they'll tell you when they're
wrong then the guy I work with now
Dorfman text me he goes amen
this is gonna be [ __ ] big for you
you're gonna add shows everywhere I went
really and he goes oh yeah I just want
to be first one to call you and say
congratulations I'm like [ __ ] it's good
to take a nap Simon up doing press and
my reps called okay we want to add 13
shows and I was like whoa and then they
call back later that day they go and add
10 more shows like my dad it's been holy
[ __ ] and now now it turns into a fact of
like I can't get from market to market
on planes if I'm getting out at 2:00 in
the morning that's one sided to the tour
bus game [ __ ] changer game now saying
hey [ __ ] that add three shows I'll do it
Thursday add three shows I'll stay
Monday have four shows I'll do you know
move my schedule around and so then you
do that run and you make good money
right like do you make like you're
making some good money once you get to a
place we're like I remember and by the
way my my lead horse this whole time has
been Tom my lead horse has been Tom
heating is that tom toms two three steps
ahead of me always I'm doing thousand
seats Tom doing three thousand seats I'm
doing three thousand acres Tom's doing
ten thousand tickets so I've always have
a best friend to call and go yo man
should I do this dot dot dot Tom's like
I'll tell you what I do so like I got a
so you have innocent in this [ __ ]
game and then I got Rogan who's like all
right [ __ ] that you get it you know it's
like it's been a really great thing and
so then once you do that and you've
proven you can sell those tickets in
those markets and they'll jump to
theaters then you can go to the Chicago
theater do two shows at the Chicago
theater do two shows it and like and
then once you're doing stuff that it's
like 4,000 seats once you're doing what
row gets dipped on Rogen's do it
Brogan's doing your something is to
bubble what Rogen's doing Rowley
Chappelle man I can't imagine what their
paycheck is I can't imagine it's crazy
I don't it's astonishing but the thing
is and the thing is is like is like the
theater the theater show is is super fun
like I love
theaters now because I think you go into
these beautiful beautiful venues you you
experience they're always cool to see
you the city will give you like a brick
or a cow when you sell out the like make
like a thing for you it's it's just
[ __ ] a great great experience and so
you know we had to cancel he shows it
wasn't just about the show is about this
Saenger Theatre in Louisiana is so
gorgeous
hey Burt can I ask you this cuz you have
two kids do you know do you have what
kind of I don't say resentment or what
kind of heartbreak do you I've been on
the road all the time and a lot of your
kids Oh
growing up is very dad and you're a
[ __ ] human being being on the road
like my girl takes me like go Tiger did
this like [ __ ] dude I miss that I miss
that
dude it's ed man like hey look I can I'm
gonna trump all you guys with all that
[ __ ] because how so I had kids I had no
money
like I would there was none of this game
to be played you just you just did the
road like no one named at or back then
you just it was called the road and so I
did the road every day for every week
but that's different because that I did
Wednesday yeah yeah you didn't want a
[ __ ] Sunday but but but in that
regard that's you trying to make a
better life for your kids at this point
but no it's still that same thing but
here's the thing dude okay not only that
only I did the road every [ __ ] week
and then every not not just like any
time I could make money I had to make
money I didn't I it was me I was making
my first round when George was born I
was making seven hundred hours a week I
had to pay for flight and hotel 700
hours a week and then and then you go to
where you get your first headlining
offers and they're like all right it's
$1,100 a week and you're like I'll take
it I'll [ __ ] jump and like we need
you there Wednesday so you can do
Thursday press and then you leave Monday
so you're it Wednesday to Monday my
moments with Georgia at that time wide
watch I'd watched tough crowded
Chappelle's Show
and I'd sit with her in the mornings
with might put my thing like this I put
her butt right here and I just sit with
her and watch these [ __ ] guys I
dreamed of being yeah like Colin Quinn
[ __ ] David tell Dave Chappelle Jim
Norton I sprang for all of Patrice
O'Neal still watches I looked at them I
was like please God give me a career
please please I'll do anything
so my anything was Hibbert we got to get
a gig for you in Sacramento laughs
unlimited I'm here I'm me I've never
said no no I've never said no to again
ever but that but they were small at the
time right so now Bert Bert Kreischer
yeah Bo Schlegel doing it here's the
deal okay number this is when my brain
works and I know it's broken but like I
go from that into Travel Channel and
then I do Travel Channel was too weak
saw him when we call from that one week
off I did stand-up so like I was never
[ __ ] home and it was jolly really kid
then who knows
yeah I have no [ __ ] mr. glory idea I
came back in South Africa one time and
my daughter was sitting at the bottom of
the stairs and she goes dad what the
[ __ ] are you doing here I mean look I'm
joking about it obviously I drink a lot
I'm sure there's a connection but but
like and then you look at it now my kids
don't know any different they've had a
dad who's gone on weekends home in the
week and when I'm home in the week I
don't drink I try to [ __ ] dial it in
down I try to be a good dad pick up from
softball go to every softball game it
you you you there has to be some sort of
you got to carry that but let me tell
you something is that is that I also
have this weird obsession with stand up
an obsession with connecting with people
and so so I already I dude I sent a text
this morning at [ __ ] 5:30 in the
morning when they said they said 10
weeks was it no eight weeks 850 people
or less I sex I texted my agents and
managers and I said book it all I said
if you got a canceled dates book it all
I said it if you think you're booking me
too much you're not booking me enough
book it all booked me from [ __ ] the
day we can start until [ __ ] New
Year's Eve and it's done that to do with
the money that I'm doing money it has it
for me it has to do with this awesome
experience of going into a city like
like like the beacon I'm gonna get a
[ __ ] emotional man yeah this and this
is what sucks about [ __ ] these
cancelling these goddamn dates going
into the [ __ ] beacon just mode one of
the most storied theatres in the world
and and and performing and doing well
and like and like with new material
doing [ __ ] well with new material and
it's tight and you do an hour five and
you're like an hour ten and you're like
dude and then and then all these people
standing up and giving you a standing
ovation and then going like
going like goddamn it man I've never
sold a ticket in New York my entire
[ __ ] life I've never said and that
that's an actualization of hard-won
paying off of not letting your brain
shut off of not letting your brain shut
off and going all I do is write jokes
and think about how I connect with my
fans write jokes right [ __ ] jokes
write jokes every time I [ __ ] I was
at a funeral and I'm some [ __ ]
giggling in the corner and everyone's
like what's wrong with that guy [ __ ] I'm
a comedian dude that's all I do you and
you're one the best part but you my
point to all this is right the beacon
you can do that all the dates but you're
still missing that time with your kid us
no but I don't see how like I don't know
anyone I just wrote it at the point he's
at now we just does a theater than fly
song there it is like it is part of the
gig it's part of the gig make it make
hay while the Sun shines
let me tell Sean Ebert hey you look you
and Ally want I said they say that so
does Rogan it's not going away I go all
right man
I've been failure way too long in my
life me too - I've have what do you put
in the time Burt
they say this doesn't work for me this
excuse doesn't work for me dude it
doesn't work for me I'll tell you what I
tell you because you keep doing this and
you keep putting the time what you have
you look at this and there you go
you know you know why I work every
[ __ ] weekend I can is so that when
people turn on that special hey big boy
and they see that opening joke and they
go oh that's good
that [ __ ] next book followed well it
said it's because I've worked that our
[ __ ] a hundred different ways and I
have fine-tuned it and I bust my ass so
that some dude who can't go out for st.
Patty's Day for [ __ ] cuz the [ __ ]
lockdown and he's like this sucks
and then he grabs a beer and he goes to
work and then no I I get all that I'm
just saying your kids at the end of the
day it don't get me wrong I'm on the
road just as much as you guys I cannot
agree to disagree with you but what I'm
saying is my kid doesn't give a f--- my
son Tiger doesn't give a flying [ __ ] how
my special turns out my daughter mom
selling tickets and my daughter
yesterday said you missed five of my
birthday's and let's do this game I said
and I was out there trying to give you
the life that you wanted that's what I
was doing and I said and and by the way
you're lucky and I'm you know I'm sorry
about that but that's what that's the
way it was you ready for this so ready
for this yeah it sucked and yeah
I was on the road and I she was really
young and I was like I'll celebrate it
that Sunday not the Friday at a time I
struggle with that that's it's the
biggest demon that struggled my
daughter's 15 years old still right this
got me not just emotional but angry so
it is I'm home I've got to fly I've got
to do press the all day this is this is
last weekend
this is last week I'm home for I'm home
for like [ __ ] two a day I get I'm
home for 24 hours right like I fly home
I flew somewhere to do press I fly home
I stayed in New York to do press fly
home I'm literally at 24 hours home and
my daughter's tour take this will dude
like this has been a fun [ __ ] podcast
I haven't talked like this at all
she goes hey I got a I got a late start
tomorrow and I go cool she goes maybe
like we could like hang out in the
morning before school and I go oh yeah
yeah definitely she was like okay so
like what do you want to do and I said
what do you want to do and she goes hey
anything you want that I just what just
hang out with you and so I was like okay
so we go out that night with friends and
we all have drinks we have a great time
we come home and I don't even remember
the conversation I'm laying in bed it's
like 7:00 in the morning and I feel the
sensation someone's staring at me and
she's standing over me and she's got
something in her hand she goes hey Dad
and I was like what's up she goes I made
you a breakfast sandwich I said you did
she goes yeah I thought we could eat
breakfast together and I was like oh
thanks baby
so I get up and I take the breakfast
sandwich out and I sit down at our
breakfast table and I open it and I said
where's yours and she goes oh I'm not
hungry
and I go you just made a sandwich for me
she was y know you'd want a breakfast
sandwich I made the eggs the way you
want them and I said really excuse me I
like a little runny and I put some
cheese and little hot sauce I hope you
like it
this little kid made a [ __ ] sandwich
for me so that I would sit and eat a
cauchy weren't even hungry and I just
sat there and I was like do you want
about where you go she doesn't keep my
daughter don't give a [ __ ] on my special
I give two shits about my special but
she made me a [ __ ] sandwich and by
the way I'm you know I'm hungover I'm
wolf another sandwich and halfway throw
it you know I'm just like where's yours
she's like like I just want to sit and
talk with you like we going this weekend
I said New Orleans and she was like oh
cool what's like New Orleans like just
pick my brain like a 15 year old and I
was like god damn it man I was I was so
like emotional about that that I was
like that problem like pushed my flight
back we're taking the late flight out to
New Orleans tonight [ __ ] let's go to
dinner like let's hang out I drove to
pick her up her softball talked in the
car it was like it man those moments my
business my biggest fear is losing
connection with my kids and it happens
all the time to people and it happens
with a lot of I know a lot of people who
have done very well in this business
who've paid that price ain't work I've
seen it a lot with actors and I've seen
it it's not worth it and my biggest fear
is what's it like to have a daughter
that likes you though yeah well because
my dad was around but he worked a
regular job but he was he was flying out
he was such a beast I'm hoping my kid
just like yeah my dad missed a lot of
[ __ ] but he's a he's a [ __ ] beast
dude but that's doing this I never saw
my dad I knew that was my dad there's a
deal I dad said the records where it was
where it when he meant something when he
came to my football games and he didn't
miss one for a long time do you be gone
all week but he came to football game
but he was off he set the tone where he
was a [ __ ] beast man yeah as a guy
who came from a certainly a father who
just was never I you know I he wasn't
around because he was working so much in
traveling so much back in the day that
that you know it is what it is but but
and then I went away to school right so
my parents were in Saudi Arabia and I
went all the way doctors at 13 years old
and I never came home so but i but I
most people to think well you know your
parents were you just never saw your dad
yeah I knew that [ __ ] loved me
though yeah I knew this is the most
important thing we're talking about
selflessly for me I'd like I don't want
to miss anything I don't know I don't
want to miss I understand that but
that's gonna happen here's the deal and
you think about this think about this is
is that here we are talking about and
the reason is because in some sort of
way
our dreams are attached to our job and
our dreams or our ego and our passions
attached for job my dad was a [ __ ]
lawyer I don't think he ever liked being
a lawyer but man that [ __ ] was
gone before I woke up grinding and he
and I did not see him until you respect
it it falls over yeah take me to
baseball biz my baseball coach but like
that was he typically fathers that
somehow whatever age do guys like the
guys like like Segura is a great example
I can say this is my friend it's like
when a girl gasps I know buddy and he
takes time off of his schedule he
doesn't [ __ ] around - it takes time I'm
scheduled to be there first kids and
he'll be like no no I'm taking a month
off yes I wish a Lee Wong I think took a
year off correct but I wished I'd
initiated I couldn't make the end be it
cuz I gotta do it but I can do I'm also
not Holly Wong you know crazy
I'm not going it's I'm not I'm not Ali
Wong be funny if you tell me I would put
a sell a show on sale and an item didn't
immediately add nineteen of them I might
go maybe I'll take it year off
you know we're like oh I don't know but
like I wish I could be like that you
know I listen to like you know I listen
like dad's where they talk about you
know it's kids first it's kids first I
don't know if our kids would respect us
if we were if agree I know I know a dad
who's been out of work for a while he's
really there for his kids at socks yes
that comes with its own [ __ ] stress
and regret and let me tell you something
that's nothing I'm afraid of I don't
want to be [ __ ] broke I don't wanna I
don't want to have not enough money I
don't want all [ __ ] well like my son had
a soccer game he signed up for this
Venice football club right and I go it's
the first game I miss his first game
they sent me video and I came to his
third game and he comes up you know he's
[ __ ] four News Papa you're not doing
funny this weekend what are you doing
here [ __ ] dude in front the other dad's
like oh we're surprised you here my god
[ __ ] off I get that
by something I said I said to my
daughter's in there that I said is it
hard being my kid because dude let's
let's not even we're just talking about
this
I talked openly trash my kids in my
specials
oh I bro stash it on my mom my girl I'd
make fun of my yeah I kid like this just
what I do
and stuff but I said to them one time
we're driving down Riverside and I go is
it tough being my kid like what's it
like having me as a dad and they're
they're just it's almost like it's
almost like if you grew up with uh with
like like deaf parents you don't notice
it maybe like it's all they know it's my
daughter Georgia goes tired I really
don't know we figure you're not a
regular dad but I don't think we'd want
like a regular dad like you're fighting
for my dad's my kids will get excited
like when we do go to parties my kids
always be like and this is they don't do
this to all the dads they'll go hey Dad
come out here and look and make up a
game and so I'll get in the pool with
the kids and I'll make up a game I'll
like make up a game but that's my brain
my very quality make up a game
hey like Chinese New Year's we went to
Chinese New Year's there's all my
Instagram stories Chinese New Year is a
big deal you wear red it's all about
gambling yes Chinese oh yeah our best
friends are Chinese and Vietnamese and
so so they go to America first right did
you guys have bat soup so I come coming
off the road and Georgia calls and she's
like hey how are we doing Chinese New
Year's tonight and I'm like yeah she
goes are you getting wants cuz it's all
about you gotta get fresh ones I go oh
am I getting once I go baby I'll pick
you up Papa's gift so I take her into
the bank I said to the lady I'm with her
and her friend and I go how many fresh
ones do you have she goes how many do
you need I said how many do you have
he goes I got a thousand I go I'll take
it so I take out a thousand fresh ones
George is now bubbly she goes hold on
what are you gonna do is she's fifteen
she goes I go
we're making tonight [ __ ] interesting
I went in with a thousand words right
you know what spoons are if you've never
played spoons is one of the funnest
games in the world
you put say to have eight kids plan you
put set you put seven spoons out and
then you pass cards around in a circle
and the first one to get four of a kind
grabs a spoon as soon as he grabbed a
spoon everyone grab a spoon and it's
like it's like musical chairs last
person out gets kicked out better than I
am so I go so I go alright guys
we're playing spoons this round 40 bucks
and they're like wow oh the kids are
having a [ __ ] by having it playing
spoons dude I came up with the game one
time you take you take ski poles and you
put ski poles across a part and you put
a beer on top of the ski pole and you
throw frisbees at it and the kids were
like losing I'm the kind of dad but see
this is where I make up a song so I'll
go hey we do we do we I mean I always
come up with parties we do the 12 nights
of Christmas every year so every year we
do 12 parties in December and then the
parents do table nice to kamasutra
where we each pick different [ __ ] moves
each to the move and then text each
other in the morning going what did you
guys think dude I like to party we play
a game called mustard hands this is a
game on white kids mustard hands is one
of the funnest games we played it with
Stan home right can bore you grab a
bottle of mustard you put your hands
under the table and you either squirt
mustard in your hands or you don't and
you put them up then you rub your hands
together alright let's start with
[Applause]
[ __ ] so we do we do mustards we get
to ila it's I live in Stanhope so ila
gets it she starts it off gives it a no
kiss Ron gets back to ila she puts up
she goes hold on can I change mine and
Stanhope goes clearly you didn't put
mustard yeah you don't know that he goes
no I do I'm a grown up and I know that
you can't get mustard back in a bottle
she goes yes you can wow I want to see
this I just heard mustard go in your
hands and she goes no that's it going
back in the box but it's like fun games
like this or I just do die you live for
it I love it we do it we do a thing or
what more my group of friends called a
preparedness party it's very handy now
but we used to do this thing where we
all got we also had a night talking
about it we said let's all get our good
and then WHAM out of that [ __ ] phone
call 15 minutes earthquake just hit
everyone at say in the intolerance Al's
and so everyone's got to get your
families get your goods and go to
Sandy's house and see if you can survive
and have a party I'm never doing this
I'd be down Oh Albertson I love it but
here's the other thing with you touring
your kids stuff like that
your your wife has to be so [ __ ] game
oh I mean your wife to be friends with
other families oh well I'm just talking
about like touring all the time like my
girl just asked me I don't think it's a
problem I have history of my family
without called my girls like you can't
drink in LA can you make me that deal
where you won't drink in LA anymore I'm
like why yeah I'm drinking right now I
said Bert's on the show it's my birthday
week
I lied I'm like Bert wants to have a
shot well I thought you would I might
have a shot for me for her birthday I'm
gonna drink today she's a great cool cuz
she's not you know she's worried because
you know whenever I do standby drink
well pop it to stand up when he's in LA
damn near every night and then I go on
the road Thursday to Sunday so I'm
drinking you've been a little excessive
love your whiskey I love it and you
drink on a Friday night when you've got
two shows yes a whole bottle you drink
Bert and they send it to me you drink a
whole bottle of 250 pounds pop now
you're a big kid to be like Bert oh wait
so you go you go the whole bottle no I'm
not really drunk at all I wake up not
with a hangover I've worked out yeah
I'll do it again Saturday night yes and
then you project something on something
I don't drink on Sunday I'm not wearing
a home with the kid I don't I won't
drink so I won't drink Sunday when I'm
home I won't drink Monday can do stand
by magnetic Sunday Monday off Tuesday
I'm at the store I drink it the store I
have a double can I have a double
and then Wednesday no laugh at you asked
me to do it so I'm gonna have a [ __ ]
double dare the Thursday I'm back on the
road have a bottle it's Thursday so
frightened of the bottle Saturday to the
bottle so we have problems without we
have problem I'll see you yeah I don't I
don't I don't
rawski I like I enjoy it and I don't
have I was this way with wine and now
I'm sort of nicotine patch - do you want
some gin so I feel that would create
them whatever yes you have a drug your
Drug Act but then alcohol but but um
like I think from me what happens as I
get older
no fine yeah me working out for me I
don't like red wine anymore I don't like
it oh how [ __ ] up is that not crazy I
love it - at night and I in the hot tub
oh don't get me tried before yo trunks
had a [ __ ] bottle of Merlot bro
trunks oh my balls floating up to the
top bottle Oh Papa hot though a bottle
of Merlot on a treadmill watching diners
drive-ins and dives
his [ __ ] treadmill red wine every
everywhere a treadmill all over it on my
treadmill and just jog it dude it's the
greatest thing either right so you start
walking it walking like a four right
just getting anything and you're like
wow I could do this all day like I could
definitely do this with a glass of wine
right it's like a wine tour almost but
not real life tour so I turn on guy's
grocery games and then you start getting
buzzed and your brain would be like [ __ ]
it let's run and you're like it now
you're sweating aggressively you get off
get into the sauna get into the pool get
in bed you've worked all those calories
all that's life dude that's like I did
it one time same time you're getting
drunk while you're doing while you're on
the treadmill I'm sorry
high on the peloton if you're morning Oh
what do you mean what do you mean I'm
balls deep and nicotine
high a [ __ ] what do you got oh this is
fascinating
oh I can nur I'm a square huh I'm a
little square go ahead I'm more on the
burt spectrum here I'm telling you man I
there's I think when we used to play
baseball you put a dip in and I could
run laughs if you like hey time to do
player appreciations throw a dip in oh I
could do it bro it's proven that helps
with cardio everything yeah dude I'm
telling you right now my wife this kind
of person my wife is I quit drinking for
like eight months once and we were in
Italy we were in
right it starts snowing in Venice we're
having dinner and it's snowing and she's
like and no one's there is empty right
she's like and I go god damn it this is
what I want to drink she was like yeah
of course I know what it means because
is whenever one wants to drink she was
listen you're not an alcoholic have a
drink
I went really I bet I stopped drinking
for eight months just cuz like I was
like I thought maybe I had a drinking
problem or whatever see look I know you
you get your [ __ ] done whether you're
drinking you don't drink if I can have a
drink and I was like really had a drink
went out went out the st. marks
brand-new snow everywhere the only ones
out there made out literally like made
out and it's a wine make out or you're
just like and then and then I'm like I'm
like let's just get lost and we just got
lost in Venice walking around brand new
fresh snow everywhere we were looking
for our tracks to get back do those
moments that's why I'll never quit
drinking and that's why that's why
Venice in the snow it was no memories
like the I mean some of the greatest
times I also riff in on stage like when
you're a little hit like you're more
deal occurred I got this bit then
something else comes like oh that's
that's that whisk there's no better
feeling is getting someone to turn like
what I would do it with mark when you
when you get a partner and crime to
drink where you go hey you want to get a
cocktail he's like I don't feel like it
I go oh like maybe like a White Russian
and then when you're drunk right and
you're with someone and you're stumbling
through streets dying laughing mark and
I get hammered one night in [ __ ]
Stockholm and we go to a strip club and
when we go to the club where we go how
is it because not that good
and we're like oh oh yeah okay we're
like we're like a bank machine in there
and he goes nuts around the corner so
we're like we walk away we're like this
seems weird that he didn't try to sell
us and was like yeah is it us he's like
no so we go to that place take the money
out we see no strip club we're like
let's try this one so we go over that
one now we're wasted we are [ __ ]
wasted we've been drinking since like
1:00 in the afternoon we're like hey man
how's the strip club at ease it's not
your type of strip club
was it guys and he goes no he goes the
girls he goes yeah and we go why isn't
an art side because these girls are
looking for more of a commitment
they want money or one we were like
bring it down to a room on the couch she
goes
I thought we'd catch up on Game of
Thrones this whorehouse I think it was a
[ __ ] heaven no we went back to the
original strip club and then L dude but
like those stumbling through the street
drunks by yourself with your friends
yeah well remember my brother's my tour
manager so J drinks the same as I do a
little live the Jade well now hold on if
I have to J has one matches two for one
he knows Japanese whiskey that's how it
doesn't start on all this so it's me my
brother it's my older brother yeah so
it's it's our experience man it's a lot
harder when I say it's the best it's the
best you need me there going hey
brothers what's going on today oh
there's nothing better you and I torn
together I know there's nothing better
to especially especially if you've
earned that booze that night you get up
you worked out you worked on your set
you listened to some [ __ ] materials
whatever things a comic you spent all
day alone writing working out you're
alone at night to turn it off at night
when you get to get upset and then you
have all the fans to turn off the fun
it's Impala is not fair it's it's
awesome father brother brother brother
we need to change the surf and turf
brother huh Joo or the surf and turf in
front of Burt no I just check it
you're getting a little buzzed of nahma
doesn't do anything he called me one
time on the road he goes he goes I'm in
Dayton do you uh do you like hang out
with these people I go what do you mean
he goes they know a lot about you who
and who he goes the staff the people
leaving this show like everyone knows
stuff about you everywhere I go people
say that
yeah I hang out with them I still to
this day I walk it to off the show when
I go I'm going to this club or this bar
if you want meet me there
take a picture I'm totally cool with it
and I'll just drink that you set the
standard because anywhere I go wood used
to do clubs the go dude you sold either
the best or the second best week as far
as booze wise until first ago Burt uh-uh
everywhere I go there dude you you sold
either mastered or right behind it I
knew whose first burnt
if that was my seed like how to make
sausage that was my in it clubs I would
go in and I would I would go into a club
I would do the best and if I could and
then one night Tony Baldino at the out
in Schaumburg said hey nothing for
nothing the nights that you go to the
bar and have a beer after the show
yeah they stick around and I make like
an extra three grand and I want it oh no
I'm just saying if I make an extra 12
grand throughout the weekend her
15-grand throughout the weekend I'm
probably gonna feel fit to bonus you on
nights that you gotta lows you know what
interesting yep so I then went off and I
said hey guys we're gonna go out to the
bar after this I get a game we're gonna
play okay we're gonna take pints we're
gonna hold them like this or to explain
game I love [ __ ] games I love a
challenge and I love a game do you you
can find this online you can find this
online I think it's called beat Bert I
go we're gonna take pint glasses and
we're gonna fill them up with beer we're
gonna hold them like this the last
person to drop their arms wins
everyone's buying is $20 dude we had
like thirty [ __ ] guys each put in $20
30 guys all stand in like this
Steve Byrne has the camera and he's
filming it I [ __ ] it's all my
Instagram's just tight Bert just they're
not mine scram I ate my my YouTube your
played to Edward forty hands no dude I
pitched his show I pissed you showed a
Travel Channel one time called the
Cinderella story where I go into a
competition with no [ __ ] training no
knowledge just nothing flicks yeah and
and I would and I would just see if I
could win it and I'd went in and did the
Scottish Highland Games long be shame I
came in third Jesus Christ I just out of
nowhere I came in third there it is
there it is there
make you [ __ ] look at this Chicago
improv what year is this 2008 right and
so I know that I'm gonna get bonus young
I look now just scoot through scoot
through so you can see the see the look
at so young I know I'm I was young I
look better now I think I do I look like
Tom both like so much better okay so
he's shirt size
okay now go to the end go to the end I'm
just gonna watch people fall out go go
right there right there
how long did me versus this [ __ ] kid
look at ya all I'm yelling is I got
nowhere else to go after have my shows
two shows let me teddy bear everyone
dropped look at this [ __ ] child
child you feed everybody watch this
watch this come on just give it up give
it up you [ __ ] [ __ ] he's collapsing
he's collapsing your arms they are
steady they're strong arms - is that
steeper let's be burned commentating I
love Stevie I'm talking [ __ ] in his face
[Applause]
look at my arms have not moved my arms
have not moved gets out that desert he
already lost he's hard he's trying I'm
just like Jesus Christ I'll be here all
day how are your arms right now they
Diane uh know what I'm doing is I'm
switching muscles he doesn't know that
he doesn't know that he's trying to do
one set it down yeah good
look at this kid he's where we at on
time he's dropping at any second now
he's gonna drop look at me that's just
at this dude this is whatever it is in
my brain I go I [ __ ] got this he's
gonna go no he keeps bending his arm
hurts saying straight this guy keeps
bending his [ __ ] arm he's dying he's
dying look at this [ __ ] poor kid you
got strong misses Chhabra uh hit-the
hit-the time how long have i hold my
hold my arm up for nine minutes yeah
that's [ __ ] oh no nine minutes and 46
seconds yes we edited it I'm sure very
few this is Shaw Bert isn't sure this is
it we do this this is the [ __ ]
machine right here Oh
two beers back-to-back spinach for
Popeye for you called it's a call a big
boy hey big boy Chicago doesn't have a
like Schaumburg way outside downtown
there's no there's Amy's but there's not
like a good comedy club in downtown
Chicago yeah they've tried I think it's
cuz Impossibles the roost down there do
we did this thing in New Braunfels Texas
they have a big
to Oktoberfest and they do a thing where
they take a big bite like a like a like
a grant like the big ones from Germany
it's fine and they did they did one
where you had to hold it like this and
man there's like a few she did this it's
a horrible verse holder that's how they
did this we did it like this it was like
20 of us or whatever and then the world
champion and I got to the point where
his head to head me in the world
champion huh and he's like and by the
way this dude's done it he did it for 30
melody does it's there's a lot of muscle
under this fat but um but uh jeez I I
did the day you see those Mark Wahlberg
dr.oz push-ups know there's a [ __ ]
weakest push-ups not Mark Wahlberg's
Mark Wahlberg did pretty legit boy jobs
but dr. oz does these push-ups though he
does those those don't count yeah anyone
can do [ __ ] 40 of those yeah they do
50 it was like easy-peasy baby all of us
look at these push-ups look at dr. Oz's
push-ups this is just that 45 that's
where wahlberg works out yeah there you
go he works out in Sherman Oaks man for
real yeah watch dr. Oz's my boys no mark
hold workshops for real dr. Oz's those
wouldn't count what if this is see you
football those don't care all right
there aren't even push-ups that's a real
account what are those well March time
do there but Wahlberg's doing the same
[ __ ] Wahlberg's kinda but you can see
yeah
even Wahlberg's winning count really
nope not used to Colorado
they wouldn't count it actually make you
restart dr. oz
ah what is this the overlaps him well
they're humping the ground that's yeah
those don't count I used to be able to
do 100 pushups when I lived in New York
and I would go to bars and I would bet
people bar tabs then I could do 100
pushups and no one ever thought I could
do 100 pushups ever I [ __ ] hop up on a
bar and just go you ready to count them
out and I'd bang out a yeah I don't use
to be able to do 100 pushups right now I
can do right now I can probably do 40 in
a row I'm guessing but I've been doing
push-ups a lot lately I just try my tits
are collapsing but um but I used to
build 100 and I remember I my buddies
from college up we're at a party and
these [ __ ] meatheads these kind of
guys that would bring a gallon jug of
water to a [ __ ] party and just and
then it's a chicken in a bag and they
did that's who they were well fasten I
said to this guy yeah I said I'd love
wheels that so I don't even know him but
I said to these guys were at a party
with all these girls that are just
beautiful [ __ ] chicks like my buddy
hutch
my buddy Blaire my buddy like a bunch of
my buddies of those frat names ever and
they did not know I could do 100 pushups
my buddy tiny like good and these guys
are like I said something like you guys
work out and they're like yeah they're
like [ __ ] bridge the tunnel guys and
I go I go how many pushups you think you
do and they're like bro I throw up dot
dot dot I think I'm good and I go I'm
hairy pie throw that up and they're like
excuse me I go oh I used to work out in
high school they're like really I go
yeah yeah I mean how like how hard would
that be like I bait them into it right
and then I go I go you think you do 100
pushups and they're like no 100 pull-ups
is [ __ ] hard bro I go oh no it's not
it's super easy like we used to do that
all the time in baseball in high school
right and they're like bro it doesn't
count
you're not that muscles start there you
gotta be doing them every [ __ ] day
and I go I bet I bet I could I'll tell
you what this is one of my favorite
things to do I've done this in pool and
I've done this in push-ups I go I'll
tell you what I'll put up a hundred
dollars its each of you put up 20 and
they're like oh do
and they go by N's 20 anyone put up and
bro I banged out with adrenaline going
and a whole party full of people right
out them out I banged out a hundred and
ten push-ups and have a gym I was living
in New York I was actually in pretty
good shape and I would just do every
night I would do a hundred push-ups and
then I would do a hundred sit-ups every
[ __ ] night yeah and so remember these
guys the other one you could do is pull
the by him was $5.00 I give you $35 if
you could win and the you would win so
much money you put two balls in every
pocket and then three in the dead center
all them touching ball and hands started
from anywhere run the table it seems so
easy but it's so if you're like Rogan
could do it easy but if you're just a
regular person who plays pool you at one
point will hit the ball too hard and
you'll have a ball up against the wall
that you'll never get back to and we did
this in the Poconos me and my buddy
Eddie against these guys and we almost
get a fight right they have now tried
probably 20 times we have $100 and I
still if anyone doesn't give him $35 and
then the guy goes all right I swear to
you on my children this happened I swear
to you on my children's lives this
happens guy goes all right this can't be
done and I go no I can't we stood on our
friend house all the time I go no can be
done and he goes I'll give you $100 if
you can do it you gotta give us all our
money back to be camp I go deal by the
way nothing to lose right [ __ ] run
the table do it go crazy Tom Cruise that
[ __ ] hi-yah [ __ ] I love games
that's the most pushups you ever done I
don't know why was fighting I do 100
every night all right yeah but but I
wouldn't do a hundred straight be like
50 break 50 to 100 sit-ups a lot of
projects doing a hundred in total is is
one of those things we did once too you
know it's like what's everyone all the
way down for me was ah no I'm trying to
get my push-ups now so I can call
someone on it I'm trying about push-ups
up because no one would think I did it
before with burn and [ __ ] and Iraqi
goes Brian wants to challenge the whole
the whole base to a push-up contest I
said no I don't do pushing I can do
pull-ups forever I can't do bleep and
this giant guy can run and I yeah it's
but I'm I'm nervous my adrenaline
Oh enjoy I'm there in Iraq we just got
in there I'm not a hamsa and I'm in a
t-shirt and this big muscular guy gets
up and I go well here goes here goes but
I'm embarrassed
I'm nervous I managed to check this out
so Steve we did good over first over
Mike videotaping it Isis starts going I
just go into a zone I got just keep
doing it I just start doing push-ups all
the way up into all the way down guys
all the way up all the down our
wheelchairs done yeah so I do the
undoing my military suburbs but I get to
60 and I go this is a [ __ ] and I
start to hear the crowd going
oh I'm saying I go what I look over and
he's paused and I keep going oh he took
a break and now I'm like oh and I gives
you that so I did 84 and he thrown look
bro but that's more than I've if you
tell me Brian you're gonna do 84 there's
no [ __ ] whackadoo eighty four push-ups
but with all those people watching oh
yeah you do it if okay that's all
competition so I learn online
you're gonna both of you appreciate this
I think our best friend Sandi's
Vietnamese now one day I see her run and
she it doesn't look natural doesn't look
like they're her original body parts
right and I go yeah you run kind of
[ __ ] up she just says to me I'm Asian
we don't run well I don't really use
google it [ __ ]
I'm drinking that night and I google it
and I google it and I find out you're
never gonna believe this an Asian person
has never won a gold silver or bronze
medal in any short sprint race - any
sprites can have told you that look it's
a mostly West African of West African
origin yeah so I get this little noodle
in my head I go to another Chinese her
Chinese New Year's party this is
probably right when I ran the marathon
I'm telling everyone I'm running the LA
Marathon no training and they started
making fun of me I get drunk and that
information of an Asian ever winning a
gold silver bronze medal comes out drunk
as [ __ ] it I can beat any Asian on a
foot race you know Asians love a good
bet money's everywhere I'm putting money
on the table we go out no do the guys I
can [ __ ] smoke right do the guys they
can smoke one guy Tom I'm a little
concerned about ya know we're both drunk
but he's he's in good shape
he's like a legit and I'm like okay I
might have a challenge on this one I'm
pretty quick so every Asian at this
party is on the streets
I am hammered I'm dressed all in red I'm
in flip-flops I kicked my flip-flops off
I get my stance I can feel my belly on
my thighs as I get my stance I'm going
this I am [ __ ] not stretched nothing
no stretching no stretching all right
count 3 1 2 3 I take off sprinting I'm
not looking at anything I'm running as
hard as I [ __ ] can and I feel like
I'm the wind I am going faster than the
wind I look to my left the two chubbier
Asian guys are behind me I looked at my
right and Tom is nowhere to be seen and
I'm like what the [ __ ] I crossed the
flat the finish line Tom [ __ ] creep
don't blame yourself
it's your people Hey Sandi's it is his
wife I go get me a tea roses never mind
I'll do it'll take you forever a woman
was unbearable I've never ever bare when
you challenge me freely improv with dove
I thought he's so big and I feel like
I'm kind of fast I try to challenge him
in her to a race because we ran that
rocky we did that fighter and kid 3d and
I notice Brendan was running like wrong
and I said to him I go like this I go I
go hey dude I go you're when you run
like this knee goes oh hold on wait oh
you know I was running like [ __ ] I
was running the way doesn't the move I
can appoint Apollo you telling me
because I never worked with any Olympic
sprinters I never I never spent my
entire athletic we're trying to run
faster and didn't work with the best
coach in the world what were you saying
like he was like oh no you tell me how
to are dead serious I was using my track
of high school so then we're in but but
I'm keeping up with him in in the TV
show he's you know I'm running with you
and then I go let's race cuz you're so
big and read the crime
it gets out it's like yeah it's like
1:00 in the morning and but he's so big
up David opposite he's so big I'm like I
feel like you know I mean I'm I'm and
I'm I feel like I'm fast I think I got
my 23 mean back I was like yeah that
fast which muscle dude I tried to race
with him and it was like he he was
literally it's like that weird speed
thing and I was like oh my god you're so
much faster
no that one time I grabbed you and I
said I was serious I go let's I want to
clench up with you
let's clinch up and I and I want to hold
you I think I can hold you and you try
to you try to get me you try to break my
clenched wrestling and then he goes do
you really want to do this I go yeah
yeah for real and he goes all right and
he just he went I just saw his face
change anyway
he's been yeah [ __ ] me up a little bit
because your brother was there I like I
hit my nose and I kind of [ __ ] up I
left my wallet and my phone on top of
the car we drove that high my destroyed
my wallet my face is all over the comic
store - he has no idea he goes dude I
see the videos you and Brian I wrestle
in high school I feel like I could do
pretty good I go huh
you know I wrestled in high school I I
bet you I give you some fritz I know I
don't know nothing I went please don't
make me do the Comedy Store 40-yard dash
I'd love to see that Tom think singing
you're both athletic guy stuff Tom's
different timing that was like a like an
Olympic power lefur Wow how about calm
looking he's gonna do a special we just
stand up in all Spanish yeah it might
mean oh my girls born and raised in
Guadalajara Mexico oh really and I go
listen us there's some girl listening
this Spanish she was oh it's really good
I mean she hates on everybody specialist
oh no it's it's really well he had to
learn it his mom's Peruvian yeah and
apparently I didn't know this he told me
this I mean told me was probably by you
know I don't I think he'd be fine with
me sharing it no nobody when his parents
met in Peru in Peru his dad was old
cia-run in Plains into Peru ran met his
mom and when they had Tom they had to
leave him
Peru up in a liking a hilltop village
just and uh I'm trying to hold on to his
life so bad I there's nothing more fun
than lying to your children and just
telling telling them a story that's so
exaggerated and they're like huh
tom was born in the Peruvian village and
every morning he would walk down to this
little bonsai tree that hung off the
side of a cliff and he would have to
water it and so that's why he's that's
why he looks the way he does he's that
there is yeah Tom is legit Peruvian his
mom [ __ ] speaks his house it olympic
powerlifter that was that see that's
true yes that was a liberal i watch them
dance and stuff I was like the guy's
athletic the guys got like oh we played
[ __ ] football he played like legit
football in college
Oh deal college you know yeah what
college if you've never seen an
attractive Tom Segura no well I think
he's attractive now no hold on first of
all active Tom Segura attractive play at
them what division Ohio State he played
it uh ok Tom's good-looking now no no no
he is not good-looking now put
attractive Tom Segura keep going
put it type in young Tom Segura see you
see if young Tom Segura comes in and
you'll say oh yeah wow look at him wow
look at this look at this gear what a
dime pee was a good-looking [ __ ] he
was yeah good-looking as he was full
mouth I mean the left side has got a
little rapey feel to it
I'm up next number 60 number 69
but yeah good-looking Tom Segura doesn't
even look like him right well yeah he's
got a full mouth he's a good-looking kid
Wow
oh he used to [ __ ] I say I agree I'm Tom
Segura [ __ ] Tom if there's the one with
the baby blue background go the one with
the baby blue
look at this Tom Segura well there's a
rough patch you guys Wild Wings
challenge a truck there's a transitional
period
oh good if you're the one right go yet
no yeah that was that one looks like
baby Huey that's a guy who's like um so
in this person right you think I'm gonna
be okay so funny he was rough licking
their Bert working to get your special
dude we
Netflix streaming now stream me now hey
big boy bird cries sure I love you guys
hey buddy I love your eyes I was the
best always a block right sure I would
say give us your dates but you know I'm
saying every single date um knocking
we're reschedule my [ __ ] you look
much older in your face looks like it
has particles my god why wouldn't you
clean that up
how's that Magnus Walker oh that's
Magnus Walker that's going with [ __ ]
Netflix put that [ __ ] picture up
that's not what you look like no it's
not your hands look amazing in that oh
[ __ ] home muscle you'll watch it now
available on Netflix a big boy Brett
crushers crazy two year old special it's
your third Netflix much of their Netflix
but to say that yep you're watching it's
up it should be up at midnight more will
shoot me up right now you go check it
out and one of the best yeah stay safe
don't go out don't get [ __ ] if I
gonna do whatever or do or do or just
live you'll be do if you're old don't go
out yeah bro crash everybody right crash
I love you guys yeah